Es gibt im Moment diese Mannschaft, wo einige Spieler vergessen in einem Profil, was sie sind. Ich lese nicht sehr viele Zeitungen, aber ich habe gehört viele Situationen. Erstens, wir haben nicht offensiv gespielt. Es gibt keine deutschen Mannschafts-Spiel-Offensiv. Ist klar diese Wörter, ich kann nicht verstehen, was ich gesagt hab. Dann, Offensiv. Offensiv machen wir im Platz. Zweitens, ich habe erklärt mit diesen zwei Spielern, nach Dortmund-Blauch vielleicht Halbzeit der Pause. Ich habe auch andere Mannschaften gesehen in Europa nach diesem Mid-Walk. Ich habe auch gesehen, zwei Tage der Training. Ein Trainer ist nicht ein Idiot. Ein Trainer zeigt, was passiert im Platz. Es gibt Spieler wie zwei oder drei, die waren schwach wie eine Flasche leer.
Diese Spieler beklagen mehr als das Spiel. Sie müssen die anderen Kollegen respektieren. Aber sie sind sehr nette Kollegen. Stellen sie den Kollegen die Frage. Aber sie haben keine Mut, zu antworten.
Aber ich weiss, was sie über diese Spieler denken.
Sie müssen zeigen, dass sie am Samstag sein müssen. Sie müssen zeigen, dass sie mich sein müssen. Sie müssen alleine das Spiel gewinnen. Sie müssen alleine das Spiel gewinnen. Ich bin müde jetzt, die Worte dieser Spieler zu verteidigen. Ich habe immer die Schuld, immer diese Spieler.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 112. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch wieder da draußen an euren Hörgeräten. Und ja, lade ein zu einer neuen Runde, wo es mal wieder um Technik geht, vielleicht ein Stück weit auch um Gesellschaft, auch wenn es hier definitiv einen technischen Schwerpunkt haben wird heute. Denn es geht um Roboter oder um genauer zu sein, es geht um Roboterfußball. Wir möchten uns darüber unterhalten, was da so bisher gelaufen ist, was man damit so anfangen kann und vor allem, wie das so funktioniert. Und dazu begrüße ich hier auch zwei Gäste, nämlich den Heinrich Mellmann, hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Und den Oliver Welter, hallo.
Hi Tim.
Ihr seid ja beide Studenten, noch?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Stimmt's?
Richtig.
Und zwar an der Humboldt-Universität in Berlin, die sich ja seit längerer Zeit mit Robotertechnik KI hervortut, aber insbesondere auch bekannt ist für ein spezifisches Projekt, nämlich Roboterfußball oder Fußballroboter, wie man es auch immer sagen möchte. Und ihr seid beide in diesem Projekt engagiert. Was studiert ihr eigentlich? Informatik.
Ja, also ich studiere Mathematik und Informatik, eine Softwarestudium quasi.
Und wie seid ihr dazu gekommen, euch dann so in diesem Bereich zu engagieren?
Nun, ich habe mich schon immer für künstliche Intelligenz interessiert, also eigentlich weniger für Robotik. Und ich bin im zweiten Semester meine Studiums dazu gekommen, also vor fünfeinhalb Jahren in etwa. Und die waren damals dabei, noch Teammitglieder zu rekrutieren. Also wir sind eigentlich ständig dabei, neue Mitglieder zu rekrutieren. Und ich bin aufmerksam geworden, dass wir einen KI-Bereich in unserer Universität haben und dass die ein solch spannendes Thema bearbeiten. Und da war ich natürlich von Anfang an begeistert. Und da bin ich dann dazu gestoßen und habe von Anfang an dann mitgemacht.
Meine Biografie ist recht ähnlich. Also ich habe erst mein Kunststudium absolviert und im Hauptstudium habe ich dann vornehmlich Kurse am KI-Lehrstuhl besucht und habe dann mehr und mehr erfahren, dass dieses Projekt existiert. Und habe dann vor zweieinhalb Jahren mich eigentlich mehr oder weniger eingebracht in mein anderes Projekt am KI-Lehrstuhl. Und bin dann vor einem Jahr in dieses Team gewechselt und bin jetzt seit circa einem Jahr dabei.
Und jetzt hast du gesagt, Robotik hat dich erst mal gar nicht so interessiert, sondern eigentlich mehr so künstliche Intelligenz. Was muss man sich denn so vorstellen unter künstlicher Intelligenz heutzutage? Was ist denn so der Konsens, dass das ist?
Künstliche Intelligenz ist eigentlich ein sehr streitwürdiger Begriff. Also überall. Und keiner weiß so richtig, was künstliche Intelligenz sein soll. Also, endlich könnte man sagen, künstliche Intelligenz ist nun ein Versuch, die menschliche Intelligenz nachzubilden. Und das ist quasi die größte These und es gibt noch die abgeschwächte These, die wir eher vertreten. Dann versteht man unter künstlicher Intelligenz eigentlich Entwicklung von intelligenten Algorithmen. Das heißt, Algorithmen, die eine Aufgabe lösen sollen, die, wenn durch einen Menschen gelöst, eine gewisse Intelligenz erfordern würde. Also sowas in der Art. Das ist eher der pragmatische Begriff dann.
Aber ist es nicht so, nicht, dass ich da besonders viel drüber nachgedacht hätte, aber dieses Wort-Algorithmus beinhaltet ja immer so ein bisschen, dass man so, naja, hat man so seinen Programmlauf und dann hat man so seine Schleifen und seine Unterroutinen und da läuft man dann irgendwie so durch. Und das ist dann sozusagen die Vorlage, was weiß ich, so wie ich Verschlüsselungen mache. Das sind irgendwie klare Algorithmen. Aber die menschliche Intelligenz macht ja einem nicht unbedingt immer so, macht ja nicht immer den Eindruck, als ob man das so mit so einem stinknormalen Algorithmus ausreichend beschreiben kann. Wie passt denn das dann zusammen?
Nun, das ist natürlich sehr schwierig, aber wir sind ja auch noch nicht so weit, einen künstlichen Menschen zu bauen bzw. einen Algorithmus zu schreiben, der genauso schlau wäre wie ein Mensch. Aber man bemüht sich. Und nun, also wo du gesagt hast, Verschlüsselung zum Beispiel als Algorithmus, in diesem Fall ist alles klar und bekannt. Also man könnte, glaube ich, ein Beispiel bringen, also warum eigentlich RoboCup, weil das betrifft genau diese Frage. Und als Beispiel für Verschlüsselung, da könnte man eventuell das Spiel Schach nehmen, weil das Spiel ist schon gelöst, also im KI-Bereich. Das heißt, es gibt schon seit 95 ein Computer, der gegen den amtierenden Weltmeister, Gari Kasparov, damals gewonnen hat. Und nun, da kann man ganz klar Unterschiede zwischen Fußball und …Also gelöst, meinst du im Sinne von ist stärker als Mensch. So, und jetzt kann man sich fragen, ist denn dieser Computer Deep Blue eigentlich intelligent oder nicht? Oder intelligenter als Kasparov? Und das Problem besteht darin, dass Schach eigentlich, wenn man so will, eine digitale Welt ist. Die ist ganz klar. Der Spieler hat die ganze Zeit Übersicht über die gesamte Situation. Es passiert nichts unerwartet. Das heißt, jeder Spieler macht einen Zug nach dem Zug und das heißt, man hat auch ausreichend Zeit zu überlegen und man steuert auch alle Figuren. Okay, so, und wenn man jetzt dagegen, sagen wir mal, das betrachtet, was wir machen, so ein bisschen Roboter programmieren, die Fußball spielen sollen, dann ist es etwas anders, weil dann haben wir Agenten, wenn man so will, die in einer dynamischen Umgebung agieren. Das heißt, wenn der Roboter nichts tut, verändert sich trotzdem alles. Die Roboter haben nur sehr wenig Zeit zu agieren, das heißt, der Ball kann schon sehr schnell weg sein, bevor man überhaupt dazu kommt, ihn zu kicken. Und man hat natürlich nur eine sehr eingeschränkte Sicht auf die Welt und man kontrolliert auch nur sich selbst und nicht alle. Das heißt, man muss kooperieren mit anderen Spielern, damit man erfolgreich ist bei diesem Spiel. Und wie gesagt, die eingeschränkte Sicht ist auch sehr wichtig.
Die eingeschränkte Sicht im Sinne von, dass der einzelne Roboter nicht immer alles im Blick hat?
Das heißt, wenn der Ball hinter einem ist, dann kann man das nicht wissen. Und beim Komprimierungsalgorithmus oder bei einem Verschlüssungsalgorithmus oder bei einem Schachspiel, da weiß man, was die Daten sind. Das ist ganz klar. Also da macht man wirklich drei Schleifen hintereinander und dann läuft das ab. Also man kann zweimal drüber gehen oder so oder viermal drüber nachdenken, welchen Zug man beim Schach macht oder was simulieren. Es liegt einfach nur an der Leistung des Computers. Also es gibt eine endliche Anzahl von Möglichkeiten, etwas zu tun. Man sucht einfach alle durch im schlimmsten Fall und dann hat man die Beste. Und beim Fußball kann man das eben nicht machen. Oder allgemein bei solchen, beim agieren in dynamischen Umgebungen, wie die Menschen das tun. Das heißt also allein das Tür aufmachen, also die Tür kann nun etwas offen sein oder ganz offen sein. Und die Frage ist, wie macht man die Tür auf oder wie löst man diese Situation, die erfüllt schon mehr Intelligenz.
Es sind schon Algorithmen mit dem Spiel, aber sie taugen nicht für alles, sondern es sind immer nur Teillösungen, die man im richtigen Moment sozusagen zum Einsatz bringen muss. Die Kunst ist eigentlich, mehr die Situation als solche zu erkennen, um zu wissen, mit welchem Algorithmus man jetzt antwortet. Hab ich schon verstanden. Was macht denn jetzt den Roboterfußball so interessant? Ich kenne auch eine Menge Leute, die sagen, Fußball interessiert mich gar nicht. Seid ihr eigentlich Fußballfans?
Eher weniger. Vornehmlich ist das Interesse an der Robotik, das im Vordergrund steht und es ist jetzt immer die Domäne Fußball, in der wir uns bewegen. Sie sind insofern interessant, was ich schon erwähnte, dass Schafspieler in sich abgeschlossen ist und die Domäne Fußball ist sehr offen und wir haben viele Teilprobleme, die wir lösen müssen. Es ist einfach ein sehr interessanter Bereich, sich dort zu bewegen. Natürlich aber auch der Wettbewerb, der durch das Fußballspiel entsteht, der zu mehr Leistung animiert.
Das heißt, auch im Rest des Teams sieht es genauso aus, oder was?
Zum Großteil ja. Die meisten Leute, mit denen ich gesprochen habe im Team, die spielen gerne Fußball in ihrer Freizeit, aber das am Wochenende Treffen zum Fußballspiel gucken bleibt eher aus.
Das heißt, es geht jetzt wirklich um die eigentliche Herausforderung der Problemlösung, sozusagen. Und was macht das jetzt so interessant, was findet man jetzt in dieser Disziplin Roboter, was man sonst irgendwie nicht findet?
Nun, also wie Oliver schon erwähnt hatte, und ich davor auch, also das Schachspiel ist abgeschlossen und das KI-Bereich war auf der Suche nach einer neuen Herausforderung. Und nun das Fußballspiel an sich, das dient jetzt als Ersatz fürs echte Leben, also das ist quasi, nun es ist etwas vereinfacht, vereinfachte Welt, in der wir versuchen, die Probleme der echten Welt zu lösen. Und die Aspekte, die bei Bayern eine große Rolle spielen, das sind die, die ich gerade davor auch angesprochen hatte, also diese Dynamik, dass man Schnelllösungen treffen muss und so weiter. Und das ist natürlich etwas anders, wenn man einen echten Roboter hat, als wenn man im Computer bewegt, weil wieder dieser Vergleich zwischen Schach und Fußball, wo eben, wenn man sich innerhalb einer digitalen Welt bewegt, wie zum Beispiel der FIFA Soccer 2005, also der ist ziemlich gut. Also die würden vermutlich gegen unsere Simulationsmannschaft locker gewinnen, also das Programm, aber da ist eben der wesentliche Unterschied, dass die quasi kein Fußball, sondern eher Schach spielen, weil die kennen die gesamte Welt dort, diese Fußballwelt innerhalb dieses Spiels und die können die Bewegungen der Spieler ganz genau koordinieren, die müssen nicht mit der Physik arbeiten und so weiter.
Das heißt, sie würden vielleicht doch nicht unbedingt gewinnen, wenn sie jetzt sozusagen wirklich auf eine physikalische Welt treffen würden?
Nein, das auf keinen Fall, natürlich nicht. Aber innerhalb dieser Spielwelt, auf die sie quasi programmiert wurden, würden sie ganz sicher gewinnen.
Das heißt, eigentlich ist es auch das Ziel, dass man diese physikalische Welt, auf die man trifft, also ein richtiger Ball, Banden und so weiter, dass man das eigentlich so gut wahrnimmt, dass man ein gutes Modell hat von dem, was tatsächlich passiert.
Ja, das ist richtig. Das ist natürlich auch sehr wichtig. Insbesondere also im Hinblick auf den Aspekt, dass die Sicht eingeschränkt ist, also bei einem physikalischen Roboter ist das klar. Das heißt, man hat nur eine ganz kleine Kamera, die nur ein sehr kleines Stück der Welt sieht zu einem Zeitpunkt und man muss sich natürlich zumindest merken, was man vor einer Sekunde gesehen hat oder merken, dass man gerade den Ball gesehen hat, wenn man den Kopf bewegt, um nach dem Tor zu schauen. Also da kann man natürlich nicht rein reaktiv agieren. Also man muss schon eine gewisse Vorstellung davon haben, wo man eigentlich ist.
Bevor wir vielleicht noch mehr auf die Technik eingehen, noch muss ich nochmal das eigentliche Projekt, was ihr hinterfragt, also eine HU, gibt es diese Fußballgruppe, hat die irgendwie besonderen Namen?
Ja, wir heißen Nao Team Humboldt. Der Nao ist unser Roboter und daraus ist jetzt der Name zusammengestellt. Das ist momentan eigentlich das Nachfolge-Team des Aibo-Teams, was halt die Jahre vorher dort agiert hat und das ist sozusagen die Namensgebung.
Das heißt, angefangen hat das alles mit dem Aibo, mit dem kleinen Roboterhund von Sony. Denen gab es seit, weiß ich gar nicht, 95. Ist schon eine Weile her. Mittlerweile gibt es den noch nicht mehr, also wird zumindest nicht mehr gebaut. Es gibt wahrscheinlich noch ein paar, die funktionieren, aber man kriegt da keine Ersatzteile mehr. Also weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es auch noch Ersatzteile, aber zumindest nicht von Sony. Was wisst ihr denn darüber, wie das überhaupt zu Standard gekommen ist, dieses Projekt?
Nun, das ist ganz interessant. Also unser Projekt läuft ja unter der Leitung oder Schirmherdschaft von Professor Hans-Dieter Burkardt und der ist eigentlich ein Mathematiker und der hat sich schon von Anfang an für Logik interessiert und dann natürlich auch für Künstliche Intelligenz. Und dann hat er diesen Lehrstuhl für Künstliche Intelligenz an der HU übernommen. Und der fand dieses Projekt sehr interessant von Anfang an und hat auch das RoboCup nach Deutschland gebracht in dem Sinne, dass er quasi an unserer Universität dieses Projekt etabliert hat und mit nun mehreren Teams dann auch an diesem RoboCup-Projekt oder an diesem RoboCup-Wettbewerb teilgenommen hat. Das heißt, wir hatten an unserer Universität, an unserem Lehrstuhl mehrere Teams zu gleicher Zeit, also das längste, das älteste Team ist das Simulationsteam, da spielen die Roboter einfach, also da sind die Roboter komplett simuliert, das ist auch die älteste Liga im RoboCup-Wettbewerb. Das zweite älteste Team war das Aibo-Team, also da haben wir mit diesen Aibo-Robotern gespielt, und dann irgendwann haben wir auch angefangen, eigene Roboter zu bauen und sind dann in der Humanoiden-Liga tätig geworden. Das wurde aber gestoppt und sie bauen jetzt Roboter für andere Zwecke. Du hast richtig gesagt, die Aibo's werden nicht mehr gebaut und deswegen wurde Ersatz gesucht für diese Standard-Roboter und der Ersatz ist eben momentan der Nao, der von der französischen Firma Aldebaran gebaut wird und momentan haben wir das Nao Team. Also das ist ungefähr die Geschichte ganz gut.
Und der RoboCup jetzt selber, der ist in Japan ursprünglich mal initiiert worden, oder?
Genau, also der wurde in Japan initiiert.
Kannst du mal was sagen zu dieser Veranstaltung, was wir uns mal da vorstellen? Ist das so wie normaler Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft, so mit kreischenden Fans und so? Also in Japan würde mich das noch nicht mal überraschen.
Also in China, wo wir zuletzt waren, hatten wir schon eine ganze Reihe an Fans, die auch schon in Fußballdimensionen angefeuert haben. Aber so gut ist es jetzt vielleicht doch nicht ganz.
Sobald euch das bekannt ist.
Ja, muss man natürlich gaten lassen.
Ja, also grundsätzlich RoboCup ist eine Veranstaltung, die nun relativ erfolgreich ist momentan. Und deren Erfolg liegt darin, dass es nun in unterschiedlichen Richtungen ausgeprägt ist. Also zu einem ist es ein wissenschaftlicher Projekt, an dem viele Wissenschaftler arbeiten und Roboter entwickeln, die Fußball spielen sollen. Zum anderen ist es ein Wettbewerb, wo sich viele, also diese Wissenschaftler, diese Roboter entwickeln, sich treffen und auch Fußball spielen. Und das ist auch sehr anschaulich. Das heißt, es sieht sehr interessant aus und deswegen besteht ein relativ großes Medieninteresse. Das heißt, da versammeln sich auch ganz normale Menschen, um diese Spiele sich anzuschauen. Und deswegen ist es relativ erfolgreich. Grundsätzlich ist RoboCup in unterschiedliche Ligen aufgeteilt. Also wie ich erwähnt hatte, ist es ein Wettbewerb, wenn man so will. Es gibt unterschiedliche Ligen.
Was gibt es da so?
Es gibt zum Beispiel die Simulations-Liga. Dort werden die Roboter simuliert. Das sind auch einzelne Roboter, das heißt einzelne Programme, die gegeneinander antreten. Das ist also nicht wie FIFA, Soccer. Und zum anderen gibt es da die Standard-Plattform-Liga. Das ist die Liga, in der wir es speziell spielen. Dort haben alle Teams die gleichen Roboter.
Die selbe Hardware-Basis.
Genau, das heißt, es werden nur die Programme verglichen, nur die Software spielt gegeneinander, wenn man so will. Und dazu verlieben. Es gibt aber noch andere Ligen. Zum Beispiel gibt es die Small Size League. Bei der Small Size League haben die Roboter Räder. Das sind relativ kleine Roboter. Das sind etwa 20 cm große runde Roboter, die auf dem Feld rumfahren. Und die sind nicht autonom. Die werden von einer zentralen Kamera beobachtet und von einem zentralen Rechner dann gesteuert. Das ist die einzige Liga, die nicht autonome Roboter hat.
Was ist da der Witz? Also ich meine, wundern mich, dass das sich jetzt so weit aufspaltet. Weil man würde ja eigentlich vermuten, es gibt ja auch diese Aussage, bis 2050 sind wir so weit und dann spielt irgendwie eine Roboter-Mannschaft gegen richtige Menschen und gewinnt.
Ja, das ist richtig. Allerdings, es sind zu viele Facetten noch zu entwickeln, bis man einen humanoiden Roboter hat, der wie ein Mensch Fußball spielen kann. Also angefangen von der Wahrnehmung der Welt bis Aufbau dieses Modells, das heißt diese Vorstellung der Welt, in dem man sich gerade befindet, und dann das Planen des eigenen, also das Verhalten bzw. das Planen des Duns des eigenen und dann natürlich die Bewegung an sich. Und man kann nicht alle Probleme gleichzeitig angreifen, also das ist einfach zu schwierig, das heißt es gibt einfach zu wenig Ressourcen, um das alles gleichzeitig anzugreifen. Deswegen werden verschiedene Aspekte getrennt angegangen. Zum Beispiel die Simulations-Liga, die haben nicht wirklich mit der Physik zu kämpfen. Die brauchen keine Bildverarbeitung, die brauchen keine Perzeption in diesem Sinne, das heißt die haben alle Informationen ein bisschen verrauscht von der Welt, und die können sich rein auf das Verhalten konzentrieren. Und ähnlich ist das bei der Small-Size-Liga, das heißt die hören sich auf verschiedene Strategien konzentrieren, also wie die Spieler untereinander spielen sollen, das heißt also die brauchen diese Aspekte der Eingeschränkten sich zum Beispiel nicht beachten. Also die haben ganz andere Schwerpunkte. Es gibt zum Beispiel mit diesen Rädern auch noch eine ganz andere Liga, das ist die Mid-Size-Liga, das ist die Liga, die jetzt mittlerweile auf dem größten Feld spielt, also die spielen schon auf einem Spielfeldfeld, was so groß ist wie so ein Hallenfußballfeld, denke ich. Und die haben auch keine spezielle Beleuchtung, das heißt, die spielen mit normalem Licht.
Verstehe, die anderen sind ganz gut ausgeleuchtet.
Ja, genau, also die anderen müssen relativ gut ausgeleuchtet sein, damit die Kameras auch irgendwas erkennen. Ja, genau, also das sind meistens farbige Marker, die an den Robotern angebracht sind oder in der Welt, das heißt, die Welt ist meistens farbig codiert, damit ja auch relativ gut zu erkennen ist. Und nun die haben aber zum Beispiel auch Kameras, also diese Mid-Size-Liege, die haben Kameras, die 360 Grad erfassen können. Das heißt, die haben omnidirektionale Kameras, das heißt, die sehen auch relativ viel.
Wie groß ist Mid-Size, wie groß muss man sich das vorstellen?
Die Roboter sind etwa so groß wie eine Mülltonne. Manchmal wird das auch gesagt. Die Roboter sehen manchmal aus wie Mülltonnen. Also die sind etwa 50 Zentimeter im Durchmesser und vielleicht einen Meter hoch. Also es hängt natürlich davon ab, weil die Roboter, die werden auch von den Teams selbst gebaut und dementsprechend sehen die auch unterschiedlich aus. Allerdings haben die da auch so Größen und Gewichtsbeschränkungen. Und eine der jüngsten Liegeln ist die Humanoid-Liga. Das ist die Liga der zweibeinigen Roboter. Also das ist eigentlich die Liga, die jetzt evolutionsmäßig gesehen die ganze Veranstaltung anführt. Weil das geht schon in die Richtung, wo es eigentlich hingeht. Da werden zweibeinige Roboter gebaut, die auch zwei Arme haben und im Wesentlichen einem Menschen ähneln und einer menschlichen Gestalt. Und die gegeneinander auch Fußball spielen.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt quasi aus jeder dieser Ligen, die ja alle unterschiedliche Anforderungen haben und sozusagen Vor- und Nachteile haben, unterschiedliche Aspekte gewinnen. Ich denke mir jetzt bei dieser Small-Size-Geschichte, da hat man halt irgendwie die Kamera von oben, da hat man natürlich einen ganz anderen Überblick, als wenn jetzt jeder Beteiligte alleine guckt. Inwieweit werden denn diese Ergebnisse, die da jetzt gewonnen werden, in der Forschungsgemeinschaft auch wirklich geteilt und gewonnen? Ich meine, gerade wenn das so ein Wettbewerb ist, dann könnte man ja auch sagen, okay, alles klar, jetzt hat die eine Mannschaft da irgendwas Pfiffiges rausbekommen. Das ist so ihr Vorteil, um auch das nächste Mal wieder zu gewinnen. Warum sollten sie das dann in einem wissenschaftlichen Prozess publizieren?
Also in der Vergangenheit war es so, dass schon eine Informationzusetzung in den Ligen selber stattfand und natürlich auch über die Ligen hinaus. Insofern war das halt so, dass dann das Gewinnerteam, also das eine Wettbewerb gewonnen hat, seinen Code zur Verfügung gestellt hat, also ihn nochmal aufbereitet hat und eben auch zum Download bereitgestellt ist. Und andere Teams waren in der Lage, diesen Code zu benutzen, weiterzuentwickeln oder ihn einfach auch nur zu verwenden und in der nächsten Meisterschaft anzutreten. Das heißt, man hat dadurch auch so ein bisschen die Möglichkeit, sich selber wieder anzusparen, dass wenn man seinen Vorsprung bekannt gibt, ist man selber dazu genötigt, noch weiterzuentwickeln, immer wieder. Und man kann es also schon schaffen, auf einer gewissen Codebasis dann aufzubauen und Sachen, die andere Teams sehr gut gelöst haben, wiederzuverwenden. Und abgesehen davon gibt es natürlich noch die Möglichkeit, die Sachen wissenschaftlich zu publizieren, die man erforscht hat. Und dann werden die eben auf Konferenzen eingereicht und debattiert bzw. präsentiert. Und es ist schon eine gewisse Wissensdistribution, die stattfindet. In den Liga und über die Liga hinaus.
Also das Gewinnerteam ist verpflichtet, dazu das zu tun, oder das wird in der Regel gemacht?
In der Regel wird das so gemacht. Verpflichtungen, soweit ich weiß, existieren nicht. Aber normalerweise halt unter dem Aspekt, wir wollen alle forschen, wir wollen alle das Gesamtprojekt RoboCup voranbringen und die Entwicklung der Robotik, machen es eigentlich die Gewinnerteam schon. Genau, das ist der eine Aspekt. Der andere Aspekt, ob man von Ligen Code transportieren kann, ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil halt, was Heinrich schon erwähnt hatte, die Ligen schon in sich abgeschlossene Systeme darstellen. Das heißt, sie haben andere Problemstellungen. Und man kann den Code nicht ohne weiteres transferieren von der Simulationsliga auf den richtigen Roboter. Weil halt die unterliegenden Werkzeuge, die quasi zur Verfügung stehen, sehr, sehr verschieden sind. Also man kann von der Simulationsliga davon ausgehen, dass sie relativ gute Daten haben, was man auf einem richtigen Roboter meist nicht davon ausgehen kann. Das heißt, man muss da viel mehr Abschätzungen betreiben und dementsprechend die Algorithmen, die darauf fußen, natürlich auch unterschiedlich zu betrachten.
Aber es werden trotzdem Papers gemacht in dieser Arbeit, also das heißt, schon die Erkenntnisse fließen ein. Ich meine, ich denke mir, klar, vielleicht kann man den Code nicht 1 zu 1 übernehmen, aber man kann ja Erkenntnisse daraus gewinnen. Angenommen, man hätte den Überblick. Und weil wir ihn haben, haben wir jetzt irgendwie die und die Strategie gefunden. Und dann kann man sich überlegen, wie könnte ich diese Strategie jetzt anwenden, in einer, was weiß ich, in einer humanoiden Liga, so was weiß ich. Ich versuche diese Situationen, die da und da klar waren, weil man weiß, wie alle stehen, versucht man irgendwie zu erahnen, so, ah, es könnte jetzt das sein, es könnte jetzt das sein und dann so.
Das ist sowieso ein schöner Aspekt an der Robotik, dass es eigentlich ein multilinäres Arbeiten ist. Das heißt, man versucht eigentlich aus allen Forschungsbereichen gewisse Aspekte einzunehmen, nicht nur aus dem Bereich Robotik, sondern auch eben Bildverarbeitung eben oder Motoransteuerung, was die mehr so Ingenieurswissenschaften wären. Und dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für die Robotik selber. Das heißt, Wissen, was hier erforscht wurde, wird halt nach außen publiziert und kann eben in den Teams untereinander benutzt werden. Es kann aber eben auch in komplett anderen Situationen benutzt werden. Also die Bildverarbeitung für die Erkennung von Objekten zum Beispiel kann ja auch außerhalb des Roboterfußballs gerne verwendet werden, wenn man andere Objekte zum Beispiel identifizieren möchte.
Wie gut sind denn die Roboter? Ich meine, mit den Aibos hat es mal angefangen. Der Aibo ist ja, wenn man ihn sich so anschaut, recht cute, aber jetzt nicht unbedingt so das, was einem das Gefühl gibt. Wir werden jetzt kurz davor, dass der Terminator mal irgendwie als kaufbares Produkt released wird. Was können denn diese Maschinen mittlerweile? Also wie schnell sind diese Motoren? Was kann man denn zu sagen zu dieser ganzen Hardware?
Okay, also die Frage ist sehr schwierig zu beantworten.
Oder fragen wir mal anders. Was gibt es konkret an Technologien, die jetzt beim Roboterfußball oder generell zum Einsatz kommen? Es gibt ja in zunehmendem Maße auch Bausätze bzw. fertige Systeme, die dazu einladen, dass man sie programmiert.
Richtig? Ja, das ist richtig. Aibo ist zum Beispiel eines von solchen Systemen, dass man einfach kaufen kann und losprogrammieren kann. Ich kann mal vielleicht etwas technisch werden. Wie gut sind die? Am Ende, am letzten Spiel von Aibos, das war in China, bei der letzten Weltmeisterschaft, das ist ein halbes Jahr her etwa.
Das war das letzte offizielle Auftreten der Aibo-Liga?
Ja, erstmal ja. Es weiß noch keiner, ob die Aibos nochmal spielen in der nächsten Meisterschaft. Wenn sich genug Mannschaften anmelden, dann gibt es vielleicht noch ein Spiel.
Aber sie hatten jetzt zumindest noch mal einen Auftritt.
Genau. Es wurde gesagt, das war das beste Spiel überhaupt.
Das beste Spiel von allen Aibo-Spielen oder das beste Spiel von allen Ligen?
Also, wie ich verstanden habe, war das das beste Spiel, zumindest von Hardware-Ligen. Das ist, warum ich gesagt habe, dass die Frage schwierig zu beantworten ist, weil die Vergleichbarkeit nun etwas schwierig ist. Wenn ein Robocupper das Spiel sich anschaut, dann kann es sich für ihn sehr schlecht aussehen. Und vielleicht, wenn ein Kind oder ein Zuschauer das sich anschaut, dann ist er fasziniert davon, wie die Roboter sich bewegen und so weiter. Aber dieses Spiel war wirklich gut. Da waren alle zufrieden, auch die, die verloren haben und die gewonnen haben. Und das waren wir. Und auch die Zuschauer. Also das heißt, die Roboter sind schon ziemlich schnell. Also die kleinen Roboter, ich weiß nicht, ob du weißt, wie groß die sind. Die sind etwa 30 cm groß. Und die haben sich schon mit einer Geschwindigkeit bis zu 50 cm pro Sekunde bewegt. Es haben fünf Roboter gespielt gegeneinander. Und es findet schon ein kooperatives Spiel statt. Das heißt, die Roboter achten gegenseitig aufeinander. Das heißt, die rennen nicht alle zum Ball und versuchen den irgendwie, auf Gedive oder Fade-up ins Tor zu schießen, sondern die versuchen schon zu agieren. Und deiner versucht sich günstig zu positionieren. Und wenn du mal die Möglichkeit hast, im Internet, da gibt es ein paar sehr interessante Videos. Und das ist wirklich sehr schön anzuschauen.
Das heißt, die Aibo-Liga ist schon der F-Jugend entwachsen. Die stürzen sich jetzt nicht alle auf den Ball. Das ist ja so dieses typische Kind-Verhalt. Du hast so eine Gruppe kleiner Kinder, gibst ihnen einen Ball, dann alle rauf. Und dann kommt natürlich nichts mehr raus.
Also beim Aibo wird gesagt, dass da eigentlich nun schon fast alles rausgeholt wurde an Fortschritt, was die Technik, also der Aibo selbst, die Plattform hergibt. Weil die Kamera ist relativ schlecht, das kann man sagen. Die Kamera hat eine Auflösung schlechter als jede Handykamera. Und die ist auch ziemlich dunkel. Das heißt, die Aibos brauchen immer sehr viel Flutlicht. Und was aber gut ist, da sind die Motoren. Das heißt, der Aibo ist relativ verlässlich. Das heißt, er kann mal hinfallen, und die können sich mal verhacken und sowas. Da geht relativ selten was kaputt. Also das ist bei den anderen Robotern, insbesondere auch bei anderen Ligen, nicht immer der Fall. Also bei der Small-Size-Liga weiß ich, dass die in einem Wettbewerb einmal, also ich, von einem bekannten Team, haben die 15 Motoren verbrannt. Also während deiner Meisterschaft. Und die, jeder Motor, der kostet so um die 300 Euro bei denen. Also es ist schon eine gewisse Investition dort. Und bei der Humanoiden-Liga ist es genauso, wo die die Hardware, wo die Menschen die Hardware selbst bauen. Dann ist es auch so, also wenn der Roboter hinfällt, dann ist das Getriebe mal kaputt. Und dann kann der Roboter nicht mehr aufstehen. Dann muss er ausgesauscht werden. Das heißt, die Roboter sind kräftig am Werken und am Schrauben die ganze Zeit. Und aus dieser Hinsicht war der Aibo schon recht weit entwickelt.
Eigentlich sehr schade, oder, dass Sony den Aibo nicht mehr produziert?
Ja, das stimmt. Also ich finde das auch sehr schade. Insbesondere, weil die haben ja auch ein Humanoides-Modell, was jetzt nicht auf den Markt gebracht wurde. Also das wurde nie so weit fertiggestellt, dass es verkauft wurde. Er heißt Kyuryo und das ist auch einer der am weitesten entwickelten Humanoiden-Roboter zur Zeit. Okay, also der kommt mittlerweile auch in Jahre. Also zum Beispiel der Asimo von Honda, der wird auch weiterentwickelt. Aber der ist schon sehr gut. Also der kann auch laufen zum Beispiel. Laufen bedeutet, dass er kann sich sofort bewegen, dass es Phasen gibt, wo nicht beide Füße auf dem Boden sind. Also der kann schon rennen ein bisschen. Also das heißt, es wäre auf jeden Fall sehr interessant gewesen, mal so eine Curio-Liga zu haben. Also ich glaube, das hätte er uns auch weit vorangebracht.
Leider nicht. Curio, wie schreibt er sich?
Nein, mit Q. Ja, nun ansonsten, wie gesagt, also die Fortschritte gibt es überall. Wenn man sich die Simulationsliga anschaut, sind die auch schon sehr weit. Aber da konzentrieren sie sich natürlich mehr aufs Verhalten. Es gibt auch im Internet, glaube ich, Videos, wenn man das erste Spiel betrachtet. Die haben schon immer 11 gegen 11 gespielt. Und dann kann man so sehen, dass die Spieler sich im Wesentlichen nur da bewegen, wo der Ball eigentlich ist. Und die neuen, also die letzten Spiele von Simulationsliga, da könnte man meinen, das ist ein Spiel in der Menschenweltmeisterschaft, wo halt die Menschen als Kreise dargestellt werden. Also das sieht schon sehr dynamisch aus und die passen dort auch.
Menschenweltmeisterschaft ist schön gesagt. Man sieht schon, ihr habt da ein sehr spezielles Sichtweise.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Auch wenn das Ding so veraltet ist, ich finde das trotzdem nochmal interessant. Wie programmiert man denn diesen Aibo? Also bis zu welchem Grad ist denn das Ding steuerbar? Wenn man da jetzt ran will an die Plattform, was kann man da alles drehen und bewegen? Kann man da mit dem Schwanz wackeln?
Ja, also im Prinzip nur ein Aibo. Dort kann man eigentlich alles bewegen, natürlich. Also der Schwanz hat allein zwei Freiheitsgraden. Der Kopf hat auch drei Freiheitsgraden. Also dem Gegenübergestellten sieht man, dass das ein Spielzeug ist. Und man kann die Ohren bewegen sogar, was für Fußball nicht unbedingt nützlich ist. Ja, sowas. Also das kann man vielleicht. Also beim Aibo ist das so, das hat einen 500 MHz Prozessor und ein spezielles Betriebssystem von Sony. Und das war lange Zeit zu. Und das haben sie nur unter Unterschrift rausgegeben, die SDK dafür, dass man dafür quasi eigene Software schreiben durfte. Aber ansonsten hat man da vollen Zugang zu allen Geräten. Also man kann den Aibo komplett steuern. Allerdings entfällt dann die Garantie, also wenn man den Aibo anfängt, für RoboCup zu benutzen, das heißt, selbst zu programmieren, ist die Garantie damit erlöscht. Das heißt, wir müssen jede Reparatur selbst bezahlen.
Aber was für eine Art Programmiermodell macht man da? Ist man da so eventorientiert bei Design, oder muss man sich das irgendwie alles selber erst mal zurechtlegen, wie das Programm da abläuft? Man hat es ja mit einer Vielzahl von Eindrücken zu tun. Ich weiß nicht, was gibt es so an Sensoren? Es gibt die Kamera, was gibt es noch? Kann man irgendwie andere Dinge noch messen?
Ja, also bei dem Aibo gibt es die Kamera zum einen, das ist natürlich der Hauptsensor. Zum anderen gibt es noch Drucksensoren an Pfoten. Und es gibt Infrarot-Entfernungssensoren, es gibt Mikrofon. Und als Ausgabegeräte gibt es natürlich Lautsprecher. Und es gibt eine Vielzahl von LEDs, die man ansteuern kann, um Debug-Informationen auszugeben oder was auch immer. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch kapazitative Sensoren, die als Tasten gelten. Also die kann man dann auch benutzen, um ein Programm zu steuern.
Benutzt man jetzt diese Drucksensoren auch?
An den Pfoten?
Ist das etwas wichtig?
Nein. Also wir benutzen die nicht. Also ich weiß nicht, es gibt ein Programm, das mitgeliefert ist mit dem Aibo. Also wenn man das als Spielzeug kauft, dann gibt es ein, das heißt Aibo Mind und nun also mit dem Programm kann der Aibo ein bisschen tanzen und irgendwelche Karten erkennen und sowas. Und die benutzen die, allerdings wir benutzen die nicht, weil der Aibo, der läuft zum Beispiel bei uns auch anders. Also bei der Meisterschaft, der läuft nicht aufrecht, sondern der liegt auf den Ellbögen, wenn man so will, weil wir herausgefunden haben, dass er so viel stabiler und viel schneller ist. Das heißt, er kann die vorderen Tazen gar nicht benutzen, weil die in der Luft sind, weil er so oft auf Ellbögen läuft. Da ist er natürlich ein bisschen tiefer gelegt, kann man so sagen.
Der tiefer gelegte Hund.
Also der Sichtfeld ist etwas schlechter, weil er knapp 15 cm im Baumboden ist. Und dann ist das Rauschen für die Entfernungsmessung und sowas natürlich sehr groß.
Aber es bringt Speed.
Und er ist viel stabiler, das heißt, die Bewegungen sind dann viel stabiler und man kann sich viel schneller bewegen.
Ja, aber jetzt ist der Aibo ein Auslaufmodell. Was ist denn sonst noch so? Ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt heute selber mit Robotertechnik beschäftigt und man möchte vielleicht nicht gleich anfangen, sich selber was zu bauen, welche Möglichkeiten hätte man denn jetzt, also was sind denn so die angesagten Kits oder Bausätze, fertige Systeme, was gibt es denn da, mit dem man sich irgendwie damit beschäftigen könnte?
Um jetzt speziell am RoboCup teilzunehmen, oder?
Ja, also ich meine, ihr habt jetzt die spezifische Erfahrung mit dem Fußballroboter, und ich denke, wer das jetzt hier hört, möchte vielleicht unbedingt dann auch gleich zum Fußballer werden, also sowohl als auch. Ich meine, diese Robotersysteme sind ja universell einsetzbar, sind ja jetzt nicht alle nur für Roboter. Ich meine, man kann ja sich auch genauso gut auf die Programmierung der Fan-Kurve, zum Beispiel, konzentrieren.
Ja, ich denke, es ist sehr davon abhängig, was man eigentlich erreichen möchte. Also wenn man jetzt einen einfachen Einstieg in die Robotik haben möchte, ist man wahrscheinlich mit einem Rad getriebenen Roboter erstmal viel einfacher, was die Handhabung betrifft, weil man sich halt mit den ganzen Stabilisationsproblemen, die man beim aufrechten Gang oder beim vierbeinigen Gang hat, nicht beschäftigen muss. Das heißt, man kann also relativ schnell dort der Folge sehen, dass man einfache Bewegungen hinbekommt, sich irgendwo hinbewegen und die Umwelt wahrnehmen und auch mit denen interagieren. Da gibt es, soweit ich weiß, einige fertige Roboter. Es gibt aber auch diese Bausätze, die immer sehr beliebt sind, weil man halt dort die Möglichkeit hat, auch den Roboter in seiner Art zu variieren. Also soweit ich weiß, gibt es verschiedene Bausätze, die halt alles unterstützen, sowohl dass man aus den Bauteilen halt vierbeinige, zweibeinige oder eben anderweitig getriebene Roboter zusammenbauen kann. Ja, das ist eigentlich dann doch immer noch die Herausforderung, dass man doch selber sich überlegen muss, was möchte man eigentlich bauen? Wobei die Hersteller natürlich einem an die Hand gewisse Modelle geben, was man überhaupt mit den Sätzen machen kann. Dann muss man halt überlegen, ob man sich komplett in diesem Bereich weiter bewegt oder ob man einfach sagt, ok, jetzt habe ich hier meine Information gewonnen und jetzt fange ich an, mir wirklich was selber auszudenken. Das heißt, dass man auch vielleicht das Interface anders gestaltet, dass man nicht sagt, ok, ich nehme jetzt nur die mitgelieferte Kamera oder ich schließe vielleicht auch was anderes an oder ich erweitere die Sensorik in dem Sinne, wie es mir gefällt. Aber letztendlich ist immer der Anspruch, den man selber hat, natürlich entscheidend. Und vor allem auch der Kostenfaktor, denn was ich jetzt sage, das variiert so vom Kostenpunkt von 50 Euro bis hin zu 5.000 Euro. Da kann man investieren in diesen Bereich. Und mehr.
Also es ist bestimmt nach oben offen, so als Intervall.
Es wird natürlich immer besser gefertigt, Teile geben, es wird immer bessere Motoren geben, vielleicht noch besser Sensorik. Aber die Frage ist immer, was möchte man eigentlich erreichen damit?
Aber werd doch mal konkret. Das klingt jetzt so ein bisschen, als wäre das ein Riesenmarkt, so wie man sich heutzutage irgendwie Mainboards oder Grafikkarten kauft. Aber Tatsache ist ja, das ist doch noch ein recht überschaubarer Markt.
Man sollte es nicht unterschätzen, glaube ich. Also wenn man mal ein bisschen einfach im Internet herumsturft und mal die verschiedenen Shops für ihre Robotik abklappert, man merkt doch, dass es eine ziemlich große Community dahinter gibt. Also auch außerhalb des RoboCups und des Fußballspielens mit Robotern. Und da entstehen also ganze Foren, die sich damit beschäftigen, wie kann ich speziell die Modelle tunen, oder wie kann ich eigene Roboter bauen, oder die entwerfen eigene Platinen. Also das wird schon ziemlich interessant. Und ich denke auch, in den letzten Jahren hat sich das immer mehr entwickelt. Gerade auch durch Veranstaltungen wie den RoboCup, dass das öffentliche Interesse einfach größer geworden ist und auch einfach Hobbybustler anfangen, eigene Sachen zu entwickeln oder eben mit an bestehenden Robotern weiterzuentwickeln. Denn eigentlich sind da der Kreativität keine Grenzen gesetzt. Und wenn man ein bisschen wissenschaftlich da herangeht oder einfach diesen Spieltrieb auch hat, was auszupremieren zu wollen, dann kann man da eine Menge machen.
Ja gut, aber es muss auch ein paar nennenswerte Marken geben. Ich meine, wenn es so der Aibo, so ein bisschen der C64, der Robotik gewesen ist, was sind denn so die aktuellen Avogas und PCs?
Nun ja, also ich muss erstmal sagen, okay, also um etwas konkreter zu werden, also quasi was gibt es da und was wird da verwendet, der RoboCup, der hat auch eine Liga, oder das könnte man nicht wirklich als Liga bezeichnen, sondern als einen Bereich, das heißt RoboCup Junior, und das ist wahrscheinlich der größte Bereich, weil dort Schülergruppen aus aller Welt und natürlich auch erstmal national und dann aber auch auf der Weltmeisterschaft, sich dort in Robotik messen. Die Spiele dort sind natürlich etwas einfacher, da bauen die so kleine Roboter, die dann eine Linie verfolgen sollten und ähnliche Aufgaben oder Choreografie wie Tanzen ausführen. Und da werden zum Beispiel sehr oft Lego-Modelle verwendet, verschiedenste, weil da gibt es einen relativ breiten Ballett, glaube ich.
Lego Mindstorms.
Ja, so etwas genau. Und da gibt es auch Bausätze. Also ich kenne jetzt die Namen nicht, aber ich glaube, wie Oliver gesagt hat, wenn man jetzt die Shops abklappert, dann gibt es diverse Modelle, wo man einen Bausatz kaufen kann und das löst man sich dann zusammen. Da hat man zwei Roboter mit drei Rädern oder so etwas, der mit diversen Sensoren ausgestattet ist. Und damit kann man schon was machen in einer einfachen Welt. Also da kann man schon irgendwie Gegenstände erkennen oder so was. Also da kann man schon ein bisschen Spaß damit haben. Wenn man etwas höher steigen möchte, dann kann man zum Beispiel die also auch Humanoide-Roboter als Bausätze kaufen. Zum Beispiel gibt es da die Kando-Roboter und den Bio-Loid. Also das sind glaube ich die momentan aktuellen Modelle, so viel ich weiß. Also es gibt natürlich auch viele andere. Und diese Roboter sehen dann eher so aus, dass man Verbindungsstücke hat und dann Servo-Motoren. Also das sind mehr als Servo-Motoren, das sind Dynamixel, nennen die die. Die sind dann selbst programmierbar. Das heißt also jeder Motor hat einen Chip drin. Das heißt also die können schon etwas mehr als ein normaler Servo. Und so ein Bausatz kostet etwa 2000 Euro, würde ich sagen. 1500 so.
Und da kriegt man dann so Satzknochen und Gelenke sozusagen.
Genau. Und da kriegt man aber auch einen zentralen Prozessor. Ja, das ist, genau. Und den kann man ein bisschen programmieren. So. Und da kann man natürlich auch anfangen, Kameras anschließen und sowas.
Und da kann man sich so einen Humanoiden zusammenbauen, aber man kann sich auch beliebige andere...
Also da kann man auch einen Hund sich zusammenbauen. Genau. Und wenn man jetzt etwas mehr investieren möchte, da kann man sich zum Beispiel auch einen Nao kaufen. Also den gibt es jetzt momentan auch zu kaufen. Der ist jetzt nicht wirklich auf dem breiten Markt, aber wenn man sich dafür interessiert, kann man in der Firma Aldebaran nachfragen und einen kaufen. Der Preis liegt aber aktuell bei 10.000 Euro. Das heißt, weil der momentan auch in Entwicklung ist.
Der Nao ist jetzt sozusagen das offizielle humanoide Modell beim RoboCup, richtig?
In unserer Liga, also das ist halt keine Standardplattform. Also es gibt halt eine Standardplattform für humanoide Roboter und das ist genau momentan der Nao, auf dem wir auch arbeiten.
Genau, also die Aussage ist ein bisschen falsch, um das etwas klarzustellen. Es gibt homonoide Ligen, richtig, wo die Teams selbst ihre Roboter bauen und die müssen homonoid sein, das heißt, die Roboter sehen dann auch unterschiedlich aus und so weiter. Und es gibt auch diese sogenannte Standard-Plattform-Liga, wo der Aibo gespielt hat und jetzt wir spielen.
Verstehe, wo die Hardware identisch ist und da ist es der Nao.
Ja, genau, also der Nao ist jetzt zweibeinig, das ist aber keine Humanoiden-Liga. Also wir könnten mit dem Nao nicht in der Humanoiden-Liga spielen.
Warum?
Weil die Füße etwas zu groß sind für die Parameter.
Weil die Füße zu groß sind?
Genau, also die haben ja Parameter, wie die Roboter sein sollen. Die müssen eine gewisse Gewichtsweite, aber ich glaube die Größe.
Die Dimensionen aber auf jeden Fall, also die Abmessungen.
Die Roboter können da nicht beliebig groß sein, sondern die müssen da eine gewisse Höhe haben. Und die Füße dürfen auch nicht beliebig groß sein. Weil das ist natürlich sehr einfach mit Füßen zu laufen, wenn die 40 x 40 cm jeweils sind und man selber nur 50 cm hoch ist. Dann schiebt man sie einfach nur so vorwärts. Und genau das möchte man vermeiden. Man möchte Dynamik reinbringen. Und die Entscheidungen über diese Regeln, um mal kurz auf die Frage zurückzukommen, von dem Wissensaustausch und so weiter, diese Festlegungen und Einschränkungen machen die Teams selbst, das heißt die Vereinbaren. Wie kann man das Spiel fürs nächste Jahr komplizierter machen? Was waren die Schwierigkeiten? Was kann man verbessern? Das heißt, es ist ein offenes Projekt, wo die Teams eigentlich relativ offen miteinander umgehen. Das ist weniger eine freie Marktwirtschaft.
Aber es gibt zumindest klare Regeln. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die Formel 1, die ja auch so das Problem hat, dass die Technik da alles Mögliche erlauben würde. Teilweise muss man ja hier sogar noch zurückfahren, so was weiß ich, um Vorteile auszugleichen. Nicht mal, wenn der Automatiken abgeschaltet, weil irgendwann braucht man keinen Fahrer mehr, dann ist es auch nicht mehr spannend zuzugucken. Gut, ihr werdet sicherlich andere Parameter haben. Was mich jetzt mal wirklich interessieren würde, ist, was für Strategien muss man jetzt fahren, um mit seiner Robotertruppe ein Fußballspiel zu gewinnen. Also, da gibt es jetzt sicherlich viele Ansätze und ihr werdet auch sicherlich mehr als einen verfolgt haben. Du kannst ja aber jetzt im Prinzip einfach mal einen aussuchen, wie man sozusagen da herangeht. Also einfach nur, um mal so zu verstehen, wie man eigentlich als Programmierer denken sollte oder zu welchen Schlüssen man so über die Zeit auch gekommen ist, wie man jetzt sozusagen das zusammenbringt. Die Wahrnehmung des Feldes, die Strategie, die Kooperation mit den anderen Spielern, wenn ich euch richtig verstanden habe, sind das schonmal so wichtige Sachen, abgesehen von der eigentlichen Hardware-Störung natürlich, Wahrnehmung und so weiter. Vielleicht könnt ihr das ja mal ein bisschen... Achso, eine Frage noch vorher. Die Naos, sind die jetzt auch schon in China zum Einsatz gekommen?
Ja genau, die hatten ihr erstes internationales Auftreten dort.
Okay, gut, dann könnt ihr das ja theoretisch auch mit einbeziehen. Aber was auch immer.
Ja, der entscheidende Faktor ist halt, dass wir verschiedene Module sozusagen haben. Also was wir für eine Architektur eigentlich angestrebt haben, ist, dass wir verschiedene Abstractionsniveaus zum einen haben und eben auch verschiedene modulare Prozesse am Laufen haben, die verschiedene Aufgabenteals sind. Also wir haben zum Beispiel einen Bereich, der sich komplett um die Wahrnehmung bezieht, die quasi das Kamerabild zurzeit auswertet und da eben Objekte klassifiziert. Und diese Objektinformationen wie Abstände, Geschwindigkeit und Position quasi speichert. Und dann haben wir darauf aufbauend ein höher gelegenes Modul, das Verhalten, was diese Information weiterverarbeitet. Und dann aufgrund der Situation, die aus diesen Perzepten, wie wir sie nennen, beziehungsweise von den Modellen, die dahinterstehen, generiert wurden, wird dann das Verhalten insofern generiert, dass wir sagen können, wir befinden uns in der Situation, der Ball befindet sich in dieser Position, dort sehen wir das Tor, jetzt laufen wir zum Ball. Und richten uns zum Tor aus.
Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen ein Chor, eine Unterschicht, die erstmal die reine physikalische Wahrnehmung macht und eine Abstraktion nach oben liefert?
Ja, genau. Wobei das nach oben ist immer eine etwas schwierige Frage, weil nach oben nach unten gibt es eigentlich nicht wirklich. Es gibt halt parallel existierende Prozesse. Also es gibt halt einen Modulapparat, der sich um die Bewegung kümmert und einen, der sich um die Wahrnehmung kümmert, und einen, der sich um das Verhalten kümmert. Und die kommunizieren miteinander. Also insofern, was ich gerade als Beispiel...
Die kommunizieren sozusagen auf gleicher Höhe miteinander.
Ja, zum Großteil schon. Also die laufen halt voneinander getrennt und können aber sagen, was sie jetzt zum Beispiel haben möchten. Also ein gutes Beispiel zum Beispiel, das Verhalten kommt zum Schluss, okay, ich muss mich jetzt also nach vorne bewegen. Dann wird halt vom Verhalten, dem Bewegungsapparat signalisiert, jetzt bewege dich geradlinig nach vorne. Und der Bewegungsapparat muss dafür Sorge tragen, dass halt jetzt die Bewegung ausgeführt wird und das Ganze stabilisiert wird und ich letztendlich halt dort auch ankomme. Und das Ganze funktioniert natürlich in mehrere Richtungen, also insofern, dass halt quasi Informationen auch ausgetauscht werden, die halt in verschiedenen Aspekten wichtig sind. Also man könnte jetzt als Beispiel anführen, dass Informationen, die die Stabilisierung des Roboters auf Sensorebene bewerkstelligen, natürlich diese Sensorwerte auch interessant sind für das Verhalten. Wenn ich zum Beispiel damit feststellen kann, wie bewege ich mich gerade, also mache ich gerade eine Kurve oder laufe ich geradeaus, also solche Sachen sind natürlich wichtig.
In was programmiert man diesen Nao?
Also wir haben uns jetzt dafür entschlossen, dass wir das Grundsystem in C++ programmieren und das Verhalten wiederum in einer eigenen Sprache ausgelagert haben. In einer Interpretersprache könnte man sagen, das nennt sich Sabse. Die ist auch im universitäteren Umfeld entstanden. Die wurde auch schon auf dem Aibo eingesetzt und bietet quasi eine bessere Editierbarkeit, was das Verhalten betrifft.
Das ist jetzt speziell für diesen Bedarf entwickelte Sprache.
Genau, also die wird aber auch auf verschiedenen Roboterplattformen verwendet. Nicht nur in unserer Liga, sondern auch in der Aibo und auch in anderen Ligen, die damit experimentieren und damit arbeiten.
Das heißt, die Software läuft ja auch noch mal klar. Wie viele Naos sind denn in einem Team?
Fünf oder was? Wir haben vier Naos zur Verfügung, wobei in China haben wir nur zwei gegen zwei gespielt. Jetzt kommende deutsche Meisterschaft und Weltmeisterschaft werden wir drei gegen drei spielen. Eigentlich ist mal angedacht gewesen, vier gegen vier. Das ist jetzt aber ein Entwicklungsprozess.
Das heißt, jedes Jahr kommt so ein Zeug einer dazu?
Genau, wenn alles so gut läuft.
Musst ja auch erstmal gekauft werden, die Dinger.
Wie gesagt, wir haben vier Stück. Jedes Team hat vier Roboter, so weit ich weiß. Ich glaube, ein Team hat sogar sechs Roboter.
Aber so kann man noch auswechseln.
Genau, so hätten wir den Vorteil, dass wir auswechseln können, falls mal einer sich was tun sollte. Das kann man natürlich nicht hoffen werden. Ja, genau. Und wie gesagt, das ist ein Prozess. Also man könnte sagen, diese drei Hauptbestandteile. Und dann kommt natürlich noch ein Kommunikationsaspekt hinzu. Das heißt, dass die Roboter auch untereinander kommunizieren können.
Aber wie machen die das?
Zurzeit, also alle Roboter befinden sich in einem WLAN-Netz. Und das ist halt...
Ist das nicht ein bisschen unfair?
Inwiefern?
Naja, ich meine, ich stelle mir vor, dass sie beim normalen Fußballspiel, die jetzt alle so Headsets tragen würden und untereinander Funkkommunikation betreiben. Das wäre schon ein bisschen fies.
Na gut, ich meine, sie können sich aber auch gegenseitig was zurufen. Das könnten wir natürlich damit aufhören. Find der Platz kleines?
Nun ja, also das ist eine der Abstraktionen, die wir momentan haben. Also natürlich so die akustische Kommunikation, das wäre natürlich, das ist der nächste Schritt.
Okay, also im Prinzip könnten sie dann aber auch ihr Modell einander mitteilen.
Das tun sie wahrscheinlich dann auch. Man könnte es tun, aber die Kommunikation ist eingeschränkt.
Durch die Regeln?
Genau, durch die Regeln. Was sagen die Regeln? Die sagen, dass man nur eine, ich weiß nicht, was die aktuelle Zahl, dass nur eine gewisse Anzahl von Kilobyte pro Sekunde übertragen werden darf und das wird auch überprüft. Weil das Problem ist ja auch, dass ein Team natürlich die gesamte Kommunikation einfach zumüllen könnte und die anderen einfach keine Chance mehr haben zu kommunizieren.
Warum hat nicht jedes Team sein eigenes WLAN?
Na gut, das würde man ja noch mehr Abstraktion betreiben, denn so ist quasi alle Information für alle verfügbar. Das heißt, wenn das andere Team in der Lage ist, das zu verstehen, was die Roboter sich da gerade gegenseitig mitteilen, dann können sie die Information auch benutzen. Also insofern ja ein bisschen offener. Das ist der eine Aspekt. Und natürlich auch einfach der technische Aspekt, dass man sagt, okay, sie sind jetzt alles in einem Netz und die kriegen auch über dieses WLAN Befehle vom Controller. Also wenn jetzt das Spiel angeschwiffen wird, dann wird über das gleiche WLAN das Signal gesendet, jetzt geht in eure Startposition, beginnt das Spiel, jetzt du wirst gerade, du musst pausieren, weil du halt einen Fehler begangen hast. All das wird natürlich auch administrative Aufgaben über dieses WLAN-Netz vorgenommen.
Aber ich würde gerne noch etwas zur Architektur sagen. Also insgesamt, also zudem, wenn man jetzt so einen, vielleicht nicht unbedingt Fußballroboter, aber vielleicht auch einen Fußballroboter aufbauen möchte, also wie das strukturell funktioniert. Also wie Oliver schon gesagt hat, wir versuchen, alle diese erwähnten Aspekte abzudecken, das heißt zu einem die Wahrnehmung, zu einem Modellbildung, zum dritten das Verhalten, zum dritten das Planen und zum vierten die Bewegung. Das sind diese vier Aspekte. Und dann kommt noch die Kommunikation, die die Kooperation ermöglicht. Das versuchen wir natürlich alles in so einer Software abzubilden. Zusätzlich haben wir noch ein Paket an Software, das uns ermöglicht, den Roboter zu debagen, bzw. zu kontrollieren. Das heißt, wir haben im Prinzip zwei Teile. Wir haben einen Teil, der auf dem Roboter läuft, und wir haben einen Teil, der auf dem Laptop läuft oder auf dem Computer. Den können wir uns mit dem Roboter verbinden. Wir können uns alles ausgeben lassen, was der Roboter denkt. Das heißt, wir haben so eine Bediensoftware. Was der Roboter denkt? Das ist natürlich ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt, weil man einfach mal zu Debugging-Zwecken kann. Und Debugging sieht auf dem Roboter natürlich etwas anders aus, weil es geht natürlich auch darum, ob irgendwo ein Integer-Überlauf ist oder nicht, oder warum die falsche Adresse angesprungen wird. Keine Ahnung. Abgesehen von den technischen Details muss man natürlich auch mit schwierigeren Problemen fertig werden, wie zum Beispiel zu verstehen, warum der Roboter eigentlich nach rechts läuft, obwohl er offensichtlich nach links laufen sollte. Und dem nachzukommen ist meistens schwierig, weil die Situationen sehr schwer reproduzierbar sind. Und dann haben wir noch einen Simulator, wo wir unsere Algorithmen schon vortesten können. Das heißt, wir entwickeln viele Sachen schon im Simulator und transferieren dann zum Roboter.
Vielleicht nochmal zurück auf den Punkt der eigentlichen Strategie. Wir haben jetzt diese Roboter. Es sind erst mal nur zwei, aber es können auch drei, vier, fünf sein. Wir haben dieses Team, aber man programmiert ja jeden. Man nimmt natürlich die selbe Software für jeden, vermute ich zumindest mal.
In großen Teilen. Man differenziert schon zwischen den verschiedenen Rollen, die die Spieler haben. Der Torwart hat natürlich einen ganz anderen Funktionsumfang als ein Feldspieler. Wir versuchen schon, dass wir eine große Bibliothek haben, die unsere Software zur Verfügung stellt, aber dann doch wieder für die Roboter spezielle Konfigurationen anbieten.
Im Prinzip ist es nur Torwart und Feldspieler, oder unterscheidet ihr jetzt auch so zwischen?
Genau, wäre auch eine Idee. Bei zwei Spielern ist es jetzt nicht so.
Da muss ja eigentlich jeder alles können.
Genau, aber was wir in der Vergangenheit hatten, oder die Idee existierte jedenfalls, dass wir im Spiel diese Rollen dynamisch umschalten können. Das heißt, wenn wir sagen, wir haben einen Torwart und zwei Feldspieler, dann können diese beiden Feldspieler auch verschiedene Rollen haben. Das heißt zwischen Angreifer und Verteidiger wechseln. Und eben auch, das ist ein bekannter Problem, dass wenn man jetzt einfach sagt, jeder Spieler handelt komplett autark und da ist ein Ball, dann würden alle Spieler zum Ball laufen. Das heißt, anhand dieser Rollen kann man auch ein bisschen klassifizieren, gehe ich nun zum Ball oder nehme ich lieber eine andere Position ein und lasse meinen Mitspieler zum Ball gehen.
Aber beim richtigen Fußballspiel ist das ja nun genau die Kunst, in der Abstimmung des Teams, dass irgendwie klar ist, wer jetzt zu diesem Ball geht, in Abhängigkeit davon, wer wie weit davon entfernt ist, bzw. welche Rolle er in der aktuellen Strategie hat.
Genau, aber die Rolle quasi emergiert ja aus der Situation. Genau, und das soll der Roboter aber eben selber erkennen. Das heißt, der Roboter erkennt die Situation und nimmt dann die Rolle ein.
Also das heißt, wenn der Verteidiger gerade am Ball ist und in einer Entfernung von drei Metern zum Tor, dann soll er irgendwie nicht auf seine Rolle als Verteidiger beharren und warten, bis der Angreifer kommt und das Tor schießt, sondern er soll auch die Initiative ergreifen und das Tor schießen. Aber momentan ist das natürlich etwas anders bei uns. Bei uns sind die Roboter komplett identisch, also als im normalen Fußball meine ich. Das heißt, die Roboter sind komplett identisch und die Software, die da drauf ist, ist auch komplett identisch. Die ist natürlich anders konfiguriert ein bisschen, dass der Torwart im Tor bleibt und nicht rausrennt nach dem Ball irgendwie. Aber ansonsten könnten die auch den Torwart auswechseln. Also wir haben schon einen dynamischen Wechsel.
Also das Spiel entwickelt sich aus der Sicht des Einzelnen heraus und man versucht, die Software für den einzelnen Roboter so zu programmieren, dass er mit den anderen kooperiert, um einen Gewinn zu erzielen. So, und dann fängt das Spiel an. Wie läuft der Anstoß auch so richtig mit Ball in die Mitte und so, wie im richtigen Leben?
Genau, also in China war alles noch ein bisschen drunter und drüber, aber jetzt in der kommenden Weltmeisterschaft wird es so sein, dass es halt eine Startposition gibt für die Roboter, es wird der Ball in die Mitte gelegt und dann wird ein Signal über WLAN gesendet und dann geht das Spiel los.
Der Anpfiff sozusagen, der digitale.
Genau.
Und ja, also von den Strukturen her ist es schon ähnlich zu einem richtigen Fußballspiel zu sehen, zu einem menschlichen Fußballspiel zu sehen.
Okay, was macht das Programm? Also im Prinzip ist er die ganze Zeit am Gucken, wo ist der Ball?
Ja, genau, also...
Wo man erkennt, man den Ball hat ja irgendwie eine bestimmte Farbe oder...
Genau, also was habe ich zu ganz Beginn erwähnt, dass halt alles in dieser Welt farbkodiert ist. Das heißt, die beiden Tore haben verschiedene Farben. Das heißt, ich weiß genau, welches ist mein Tor anhand der Farbe. Und der Ball ist orange, das heißt auch eindeutig repräsentiert. Und das Feld ist grün und hat weiße Linien. Das heißt, es ist unsere relativ begrenzte Domäne. Und in der befinden wir uns und können halt anhand dieser Farbkodierung im Bild dann erkennen, was für Objekte wir vor uns haben und wie wir diese Objekte halt zu bewerten haben.
Genau, und nun ja, also das war einfach die Bildverarbeitung. Einfach nur, weil die Bildverarbeitung das aufwendigste ist, was man eigentlich...
Macht ihr das komplett in Software, oder gibt es da schon spezielle Hardware-Steine, die diese Bildverarbeitung unterstützen?
Nein, also wir machen das komplett in Software, weil der Roboter ist aus universellen Komponenten aufgebaut. Also der hat einen Geode-Prozessor und das ist ein ganz normaler Embedded-PC. Und die Kamera ist eine ganz normale Webcam. Das heißt, wir haben nur Standard-Komponenten und müssen alles in Software nachbilden.
Und die haben ja auch keine Stromversorgung, sondern die arbeiten alle mit Batterien. Wie lange rennen die so?
40 Minuten.
Ja, 40 Minuten ist angepeilt.
Aber ihr müsst generell schon auch Strom sparen?
Genau, wobei das Stromsparen vor allem über die Motorenansteuerung realisiert wird. Das heißt, wenn ich die Motoren mit voller Last betreibe, dann werden die 40 Minuten schnell mal 25 Minuten. Das heißt, wir müssen selber ein bisschen darauf aufpassen, dass wenn wir gerade Bewegungsabläufe generieren, dass wir sie so generieren, dass wir wenig Strom dabei verbrauchen. Also die Motoren halt nur mit halber Kraft ansteuern.
Das ist ja auch wieder wie im richtigen Leben. Ich meine, wenn du dich so ein Spiel als kaputt hältst, das hat ja auch keinen Sinn.
Das stimmt, aber die Spielzeit ist auch so ein bisschen anders dimensioniert. Das heißt, es gibt auch zwei Runden und eine Pause dazwischen. Aber eine Runde dauert halt 10 Minuten. Und das heißt, die Roboter poweren sich schon nicht aus. Das heißt, wenn man ein paar Ersatzakkus hat und die frisch geladen hatten...
Eine Halbzeit sind 10 Minuten?
Ja, eine Halbzeit sind 10 Minuten.
Und es gibt also auch Halbzeiten?
Es gibt zwei.
Das wird dann auch gewechselt und dann muss man auf die andere Farbe zureden?
Genau, weil die Tore insbesondere auch andere Farbe haben. Ein Tor ist gelb, das andere ist blau. Und das kann sein, dass unter gegebenen Lichtbedingungen das eine Tor ist einfacher zu erkennen. Einfach mal von der Bildverarbeitung her und um keine Vorteile einem Team zu geben, werden dann die Seiten auch getauscht. Und die Roboter selbst, die sind auch farbmarkiert. Also die sind blau und rot. Und bei den Aibos war das so, dass man auch die Farbe des Teams getauscht hat.
In einer Halbzeit sozusagen? Das heißt, man kann auch sozusagen Freund und Feind auseinanderhalten?
Ja, natürlich. Also das kann man auch sehr gut verwenden.
Waren die dann so Trikots oder wo ist diese Farbe?
Bei den Aibos war das so, dass man die einfach aufklebt. Also das waren so spezielle Sets, die für sehr viel Geld verkauft wurden. Wo man dann so aufklebt. Also das war eine spezielle Marktnische, kann man sagen. Und bei dem Nao ist es so, dass er einfach Plastikteile hat, die bestimmte Farbe haben. Also manche sind rot und die anderen sind blau. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt zwei rote und zwei blaue Naos.
So, jetzt will ich aber nochmal zurück zum Spiel. Also ich bin jetzt ein Roboter und stehe da irgendwie rum. Und der Ball wird freigegeben per digitalen PIF. Und was geht mir jetzt durch den Kopf?
Als erstes versuche ich, den Ball zu finden.
Wie gut können diese Naos gucken?
Also was haben die für ein Blickfeld? Die haben mal 50x in der Breite und in der Höhe 40 oder so. So in dem Dreh.
Also nicht so viel.
Nein, ist jetzt nicht viel. Also der Nao wurde jetzt, muss ich dazu sagen...
Hat der ein Auge oder zwei?
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Also in China, da hatte der Nao nur eine Kamera, die so ein bisschen in der Stirn war. Der hatte zwei LED-Augen, aber damit kann er nicht gucken. Der hatte nur eine Kamera in der Stirn. Und wir haben bei dem Spiel festgestellt, dass der Nao, wenn er seinen Kopf ganz nach unten dreht, etwa 50 Zentimeter vor sich nichts sieht. Das heißt also, wenn der Ball genau vor ihm liegt, also was eigentlich die wichtigste Situation wäre, kann er den Ball nicht sehen.
So ein toter Winkel.
Ja genau, also du musst also blind gucken, schießen, oder müsst er eben. Und nun also der Nao ist jetzt in der Entwicklung. Das heißt, es ist ein Prototyp im Wesentlichen. Und die Entwickler, also die Firma Aldebaran, hat eben darauf in dem reagiert, indem wir einfach eine zweite Kamera eingebaut haben, vertikal nach unten. Also das heißt, die befinden sich etwa da, wo bei den Menschen die Nase wäre oder der Mund, irgendwo dazwischen. So das heißt, wir haben jetzt zwei Kameras. Das ist nicht unbedingt biologisch motiviert.
In der Humanoid-Liga wäre das dann wieder verboten, oder?
Ja, das wäre verboten.
Da müssen schon zwei Augen vorhanden sein und auch an der richtigen Stelle?
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Es gibt Roboter, die eine Bauchkamera haben. Das stimmt.
Das klingt mir nach der Zyklopen-Liga, wenn du das.
Das stimmt, aber die meisten Humanoiden-Ligas haben nur eine Kamera.
Ist denn die dreidimensionale Bildwahrnehmung nicht essentiell oder hilfreich?
Das ist sehr schwierig. Die Berechnungen sind immens aufwendig. Da wir nur diesen relativ begrenzten Rechenpower zur Verfügung haben, sind wir schon sehr beschäftigt, ein normales Bild von 644x84 zu verarbeiten. Simultan arbeiten wir auf kleineren Auflösungen und haben auch selbst da schon Zeitprobleme. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt anfangen mit zwei Kameras, die wir simultan verarbeiten und das Bild auch noch konsolidieren müssten, da würde Roboter nicht mehr viel anders machen können.
Aber wie soll man denn sonst den Abstand zum Ball wahrnehmen?
An der Größe? Ja, an der Größe des Balls zum einen. Zum anderen hat man auch ein Modell von sich selbst. Das heißt, man weiß, wo die Kamera relativ zum Fußboden ist. Und mithilfe dieses Modells kann man natürlich alles, was man sieht, auf den Boden projizieren und die Entfernung bestimmen. Das ist natürlich mit gewissem Rauschen verbunden, weil wenn man läuft, dann schwankt das auch. Und man weiß auch nie wirklich so genau, wo die Kamera ist. Aber an diesen Stellen wird eben geforscht, also wie man das besser modellieren kann oder wie man das besser berechnen kann. Aber ansonsten kann man natürlich die Entfernung und die Ausrichtung von allen Objekten, so von Linien, Toren und von Wahlen.
Wenn man keine Räder hat und einfach läuft, dann geht die Kamera auch die ganze Zeit hoch und runter.
Die wackelt ein bisschen.
Und das heißt, als erstes macht man eine Bildstabilisierung? Oder was hat man da so für Strategien, um das Bild irgendwie... Ich meine, das ist ja das, was unser Gehirn automatisch macht. Wenn wir laufen, nehmen wir ja ein wackelndes Bildes in der Regel so nicht wahr. Weil das Gehirn sozusagen eine Bildstabilisierung macht. Macht ihr das auch in Software?
Nee, das macht man nicht. Wir machen keine Bildstabilisierung in dem Sinne. Was wir machen... Okay, also die Verarbeitung des Bildes, das unterteilt sich in verschiedenen Aspekten. Zuerst die eigentliche Bildverarbeitung, das heißt das Finden der interessanten Objekte im Bild, jetzt unabhängig davon, ob der Roboter dabei geschwankt hat oder nicht. Also einfach nur Objekte im Bild finden. Und dann der zweite Punkt natürlich, ist die Modellierung. Also das heißt, was ich angesprochen hatte, das heißt Aufbau der Vorstellung über die Welt. Dort fließen dann solche Informationen ein, wie die Informationen darüber, wo die Kamera eigentlich ist, relativ zum Boden. Und das können wir aus den Gelenken auslesen. Das heißt, wir können die Position der Kamera berechnen. Und dann können wir diese Objekte auf den Boden projizieren. Und dann haben wir relative Koordinaten zu dem Roboter. Das heißt, wir haben die Entfernung und wir haben den Winkel zu dem Ball. Und das ist dann auch die interessante Information, die vom Verhalten verarbeitet wird. Das heißt, ob die Kamera dann dabei schräg war oder nicht, interessiert dann nicht wirklich. Es interessiert nicht wirklich, wenn es sich gut in dieser Transformation wiedergespiegelt. Das heißt, wenn ich weiß, dass meine Kamera geneigt war anhand meiner Gelenkdaten, dann ist es kein Problem. Weil das fließt in diese Projektion mit rein. Und in dieser Projektion, da stecken keine Bildinformationen mehr drin.
Das ist eine bildstabilisierung. Bloß keine Bildstabilisierung, die aufs Bild geht, sondern die gleich aus der Auswertung heraussteht. Das Stabilisiert das Modell. Verstehe. Ich weiß jetzt, wo der Ball ist.
Richtig. Nun, dann... Dann... Das ist jetzt...
Jetzt wird es schwierig.
Das ist die wesentliche Frage. Was mache ich damit? Unsere Strategie in unserem Team ist, möglichst schnell zum Ball zu kommen und möglichst in Bewegung bleiben. Das heißt, ich versuche mir... Also Ball ist natürlich der wichtigste Objekt im Spiel. Und ich versuche immer, den Ball zu beobachten. Aber ich kann nicht die ganze Zeit auf den Ball schauen, weil ich muss auch eine gewisse Vorstellung, zumindest grob davon haben, wo ich eigentlich bin und wo eigentlich der Ball hin soll. Weil das ist nicht ganz unwesentlich. Einfach nur den Ball zu kicken bringt nichts. Man muss auch wissen, wohin man kickt. Also am besten nicht in das eigene Tor. Und dazu schaut man sich auch andere Objekte an. Dazu muss man ab und zu mal vom Ball wegschauen und sich merken, wo der Ball war. Das heißt, man muss mal die Tore anschauen und die Linien, um sie selbst zu lokalisieren. Also das ist ein wesentlicher Aspekt unserer Forschung, die wir jetzt auch betreiben. Das heißt, wir versuchen ein Modell davon zu bilden, wo der Roboter sich auf dem Feld befindet.
So.
Terminent.
Das heißt also, der hat etwas mehr...
Weiß er dann immer nur, wenn man jetzt sozusagen um sich herum guckt? Also ich stelle mir vor, ich gucke nach links und nach rechts, ich sehe das Tor, ich sehe die Linien, dann kann ich da irgendwie die Winkel schnell ausrechnen und dann weiß ich ziemlich genau, wo ich bin. Macht er das dann, wenn ich dann irgendwie zehn Schritte nach vorne laufe, muss er das dann erst wiederholen, diese Kalibrierung, oder rechnet er diese zehn Schritte da schon mit ein? Jetzt bin ich in die Richtung gegangen, jetzt bin ich wahrscheinlich da.
Ja, natürlich. Also es ist keine Kalibrierung in dem Sinne. Das ist schon ein Modell davon. Das heißt, Selbstlokalisierung funktioniert bei uns im Wesentlichen so, dass man die visuellen Informationen hat, aber natürlich auch die Bewegungsdaten. Das heißt, das Bewegungsmodell. Das heißt, wenn ich zehn Schritte nach vorne mache, weiß ich, dass ich zehn Schritte nach vorne gemacht habe. Und ich weiß auch ungefähr, wie lang die sind. Das heißt, ich rechne das mit dazu. Das ist etwas zu vergleichen damit, dass man die Augen zumacht und dann einfach losläuft, blendet. Also man kann dann nun gewissermaßen genau dann laufen. Also irgendwann mal ist man auch sehr schnell unsicher. Das heißt, nach drei Metern weiß man nicht mehr, ob man jetzt rechts abbiegen müsste jetzt in die Tür oder ob man jetzt noch paar Schritte weitergehen sollte. Aber man hat eine gewisse Ahnung davon. Das heißt, das Modell wird schlechter, wenn man nicht drum schaut. Das heißt, wenn man kein Objekt sieht, sondern nur rumläuft und auf den Ball guckt bzw. auf dem Boden, dann wird das natürlich sehr unsicher. Aber die Vorstellung davon, wo wir sind, haben wir eigentlich immer nur mit unterschiedlicher Sicherheit. Das heißt, damit muss man auch hantieren.
Und der Roboter weiß auch sozusagen, wie schlecht sein Modell gerade ist. Er kann das bewerten. Er weiß, jetzt habe ich solange keine verlässlichen Daten ausgewertet. Jetzt ist alles Fassi.
Genau. Also wir machen das zum Beispiel so. Das nennt sich so ein Partikelfilter. Das heißt, wir haben unterschiedliche Partikel und Partikel sind bei uns einfach Hypothesen darüber, wo ich bin. Das heißt, am Anfang weiß der Roboter überhaupt nicht, wo er ist. Und der sagt, na gut, also ich könnte rein theoretisch überall sein. Das heißt, der wirft rein zufällig über das ganze Feld, über sein mentales Feld, wirft er solche kleine Pfeile, die seine Position beschreiben. Das heißt Position und Ausrichtung. Und die wirft er überall hin. Und die sind dann so gleich verteilt, gleich gestreut. So, und dann schaut er rum und gewinnt irgendwelche Informationen. Das heißt, er hat ein Tor gesehen. Danach geht er alle diese Pfeile durch und fragt sich, wie wahrscheinlich war das denn, dass ich von diesem Pfeil das Tor gesehen habe. Und wenn der Pfeil zum Beispiel in eine ganz andere Richtung gedreht ist, dann sagt er, naja, also da kann ich nicht sein. Und dann streicht er diesen Pfeil und lässt nur die, die eben wahrscheinlich waren. Okay? Und die, die er gestrichen hat, wirft er nochmal und so weiter. Und so sammeln sich die Pfeile an den Stellen, wo eben der höchstwahrscheinlich ist. Und natürlich, wenn er nur die Linien sieht, sagen wir mal, und sieht, dass er einen Meter vor einer Linie ist, aber keine weitere Information hat, dann kann man anhand dieser Information ja nur wissen, dass man irgendwo vor einer Linie steht. Das heißt, dann verteilen sie die Partikel so ein bisschen entlang, oder diese Hypothesen entlang der Linien. Und wenn man dann den Ball hat, dann ist klar, diese Information ist relativ unsicher. Das heißt, ich weiß nicht wirklich genau, wo ich bin. Ich weiß eben, dass ich neben einer Linie bin, und ich weiß, dass ich einen Ball habe. Das ist dann schwierig zu entscheiden, was man zu tun hat.
Diese Naos haben keine Beschleunigungs-Sensoren?
Doch, existieren.
Könnten die da nicht behilflich sein bei der Positionierung?
Na ja, die Positionierung ist ja an sich auch immer... Man muss erst einmal dazu sagen, dass der Roboter immer von sich als Ursprung ausgeht. Das heißt, alles, was er wahrnimmt, ist relativ zu ihm selber zu sehen. Das heißt, es gibt kein globales Feld. Das heißt, die Beschleunigungs-Sensoren könnten jetzt nur Ausgabe darüber treffen, wie er sich jetzt ein bisschen bewegt hat.
Klar, aber das war ja das, worüber wir gerade geredet haben. Ich weiß einmal, wo ich bin und dann fange ich an, mich zu bewegen. Jetzt kann ich im Kopf 10 Schritte zählen oder ich kann auch konkret messen, wie viel ich mich in X und Y bewegt habe.
Natürlich, das könnte man auch benutzen. Aber das ist nun äquivalent dazu, dass man einfach, wir nennen das Odometrie, dass man einfach weiß, wenn ich nach vorne gehe, ich weiß ja, was ich tue, dann bin ich so und so weit gegangen. Also die Beschleunigungs-Sensor...
Die laufen auch nicht, die Roboter, die schreiten. Also man hat niemals beide Füße in der Luft oder so.
Nein, das Laufen ist in diesem Sinne Gehen.
Oder Stolzieren.
Also die Beschleunigungs-Sensoren könnten bei der Selbstlokalisierung an der Stelle helfen, wenn zum Beispiel der Roboter hinfällt. Dann weiß er, wenn man die Beschleunigungs-Sensoren jetzt nicht inkorporiert, dann weiß man nicht, in welche Richtung man gefallen ist. Und wenn man jetzt aufsteht...
Dann muss man feststellen, dass man hingefallen ist.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig.
Das könnte man auch ganz gut aus Beschleunigungs-Sensoren. Und man weiß auch gleich, wie schnell man auf die Fresse gefallen ist.
Und vor allem, die Roboter, die wir jetzt haben, die sind relativ fragil. Und wir wollen auch die Beschleunigungs-Sensoren eventuell dazu zu verwenden, um den Fall ein bisschen eventuell abzumildern. Dass er quasi die fragilsten Teile versteckt, bevor er sich auf die Fresse packt.
Gibt es eigentlich auch Fouls? Und einen Schiedsrichter?
Und es gibt einen Schiedsrichter, ja.
Und dann wird digital wieder abgepfiffen über Wilan?
Ja, genau. Das heißt, die Roboter haben die Nummern. Und der Schiedsrichter sagt Nummer so und so. Und so und so ein Foul.
Aber der Schiedsrichter ist jetzt ein richtiger Mensch?
Ja, das ist ein richtiger Mensch. Also so weit sind wir noch nicht.
Das wäre ja auch nochmal ein Sport, die Schiedsrichter-Roboter noch dazu zu bauen.
Also nur als interessanten Foul zum Beispiel, gibt es im richtigen Fußball nicht. Das heißt bei uns Ball-Holding. Das heißt, man darf den Ball nicht länger als 30 Sekunden...
Es gibt keine richtigen Fouls? Na doch, doch, gibt es. Nur in Form des Festhalten eines Balls.
Na ja, es gibt noch weitere. Also man darf zum Beispiel nicht in den Strafraum, in den eigenen, als Feldspieler.
Und wenn man jetzt einfach so einen anderen Roboter einfach so wegkickt?
Nee, das darf man auch nicht.
Oder am Bein stellt oder so?
Das ist sehr ein interessanter Punkt. Also mit Öl kann man zumindest in unserer Liga keinen bespringen, aber bei den Fouls, wenn man jetzt einen Roboter umgeschubst hat, ist es sehr schwierig zu entscheiden, war das jetzt Absicht oder war das einfach nur Unfähigkeit, was anderes zu tun? Weil wenn der Roboter einfach vorwärts läuft, dann fragt man sich, was läuft da für ein Programm? Und das ist nicht nur ein witziger Aspekt, weil der ist auch relativ tiefgründig, weil das hat etwas mit Zuschreibung zu tun. Das heißt, wie interpretiert der Mensch das Verhalten des Roboters?
Wenn der Schiedsrichter jetzt einen Foul pfeift, dann kommt das aber sofort auch als digitales Signal über WLAN. Das heißt, die wissen, dass es abgepfiffen ist?
Genau.
Und dann geht man wahrscheinlich auch gleich so in die Ich-war-s-nicht-Haltung. Hände hoch, nichts gemacht, ich weiß von gar nichts.
Also bei den Naos ist das noch nicht so, aber die Aibo sind dann in eine Stellung gegangen, in dem die am einfachsten vom Feld weg transportiert werden können. Also das heißt, es war eine vorgeschriebene Stellung, die müssen den Kopf nach unten und quasi stehen bleiben, dann kann der Schiedsrichter den wegnehmen. Also es gibt drei Referees.
Man glaubt auch, dass das Feld ist verwiesen werden. Es gibt auch richtig so rote Karte und so.
Ja, naja, das ist auch die einzige Bestrafung, die man den Spieler so machen kann.
Als Zeitstrafe?
Ja, das heißt, es gibt immer eine Zeitstrafe. Das heißt, wenn der Roboter zum Beispiel den Ball länger als 30 Sekunden besitzt hatte, dann wird er des Ball Holdings angeklagt. Dann wird er eben in diesen Ruhemodus versetzt und dann irgendwo hin das Feld gesetzt. Dann bleibt er auch da 30 Sekunden. Dann wird er an der Ecke wieder eingesetzt. Das heißt, dir fehlt dann diese Zeit mit dem Team.
Verstehe.
Genau, und bei einem Nao Team, bei einem Neuen, da kann man zum Beispiel auch den Ball nicht mit der Hand berühren, es sei denn, man ist Torwart und man ist im Strafraum. Dann geht das auch.
Wie sich das so gehört beim Fußball?
Genau.
Aber gerade diese Regeln sind immer wieder diskussionswürdig. Wir hatten jetzt in China halt diverse Regeln, die uns so ein bisschen, gerade wegen der Fragilität der Roboter, einschränken sollten, dass es halt wenig Körperkontakt zwischen Robotern gibt und wenn möglich die Roboter auch nicht umfallen. Das heißt, dieses Ball-Holding wurde extrem ausgelegt, fast in der Art, dass wenn ein Roboter auf dem Weg zu einem Ball war, dann durfte der andere Roboter nicht intervenieren. Das war sehr, sehr abgesichert das ganze System. Jetzt in den neuen Regeln, die jetzt vor kurzem bekannt gegeben wurden, ist es alles ein bisschen dynamischer und die Roboter haben auch mehr Möglichkeiten, sich gegenseitig den Ball abzunehmen. Aber man muss halt sehen, wie praktikabel die Regeln letztendlich sind. Also es hat halt keinen Anlösen davon, wenn die Roboter alle Möglichkeiten haben, sich gegenseitig zu behindern und dann entweder immer der Roboter vom Spielfeld genommen werden muss bei den kleinsten Gelegenheit. Das würde den Spielverlust einfach nur behindern, weil die Roboter einfach nicht besonders schnell sind. Das heißt, wenn der Roboter irgendwo am Rand eingesetzt wird, dann dauert das eine Zeit, bis er wieder zurück zu seinen Positionen und den Ball wieder erreicht hat. Das heißt, das nimmt die Dynamik raus. Auf der anderen Seite hat auch keiner was davon, wenn die Roboter sich gegenseitig damit umwerfen und vielleicht dabei kaputt gehen. Also man muss so ein bisschen abwägen, was man da jetzt genau macht. Und wie es in China war, war vor allem der Aspekt, dass die Roboter heil bleiben sollen und dass wir spielfähig sind, weil halt die Roboter sehr fragil waren. Jetzt mit der neuen, also wir haben auch eine neue Version des Roboters bekommen, aufgrund der ganzen Erfahrungen, die wir im letzten Jahr gemacht haben. Der ist stabiler und wir gehen auch davon aus, dass wir da mehr Möglichkeiten haben, dass er auch mal umfallen kann und wieder aufstehen kann und all diese Geschichten, die eigentlich zum Fußballspiel dazugehören. Und dementsprechend wurden auch die Regeln angepasst. Jetzt muss man mal sehen, wie praktikabel die Regeln sind. Also es ist so ein bisschen, man fühlt so ein bisschen, wie gut sind die Regeln und passt sie dann dementsprechend an.
Es ist einfach so ein fortlaufender Prozess.
Genau, es ist also nichts Festes, wo man sagt, das ist die Regel daran, das wird mit einem Regelsatz gespielt. Und dann wird sich eingeschaut, das Hauptziel ist, man möchte Fußball spielen, man möchte gute Spiele machen. Und wenn die Regeln das nicht unterstützen, dann werden die abgeändert. Das ist also nicht irgendwie ein festes, starres System.
Wie viel Arbeit geht denn eigentlich ins Training? Also ich habe meinen Vergleich mit der realen Welt, aber ich könnte mir ja vorstellen, wenn ich jetzt einen normalen Fußballer habe und ich möchte, dass der erfolgreich im Team spielt, dann hängt natürlich Kooperation und was nicht alles da dran, aber er muss ja auch die Basic Skills irgendwie drauf haben. Also so schießen können, zum Beispiel wäre er schon mal nicht von Nachteil, aber auch so generell Ballkontrolle. Also wie flexibel könnt ihr denn diesen humanoiden steuern? Ich meine, habt ihr dieselben Bewegungsfreiheiten, wie jetzt bei Menschen, kann ich das Bein in sich drehen, kann ich den Ball führen? Habt ihr ein Konzept von Ballkontrolle, was weiß ich, kann ich da irgendwie rumtäntern mit dem Ball oder so?
Das ist sehr schwierig. Daher sind wir natürlich viel mehr eingeschränkt als ein normaler Mensch. Schon allein deswegen, weil wir keine taktilen Sensoren überall haben, also sprich keine Haut. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Ball schieße, dann fühle ich förmlich den Schuss. Also ich fühle, ob er gut war oder nicht. Oder was auch immer. Ob es gepasst hat. Genau, wenn man andere Dinge tut. Und das hat der Roboter natürlich nicht. Also der kann relativ schwer abschätzen, ob er jetzt gut getroffen hat oder nicht. Also bei uns geht es eher so weit, dass wenn man den Ball getroffen hat, dann war es gut. So was in der Art. Das heißt, die Ballkontrolle ist eigentlich relativ schwierig, weil das heißt, dribbeln, da sind wir dabei, uns das noch zu überlegen. Aber das wird relativ schwierig sein. Das heißt, den Ball einfach zu dribbeln vor sich und immer die Kontrolle darüber zu halten.
Also, man ist den Ball überhaupt erst mal zu führen.
Ja, genau. Weil sozusagen die Roboter, die sind schon etwas tollpatschig.
Ja, den Eindruck machen die Videos dann immer so viel.
Also beim Aibo war das eben so, dass die den Ball immer so kontrolliert haben, dass die inzwischen den vorderen Pfoten und mit der langen Schnauze einfach eingegriffen haben. Und dann hatten die natürlich sehr präzise Kontrolle darüber, weil dann kann der Roboter sich irgendwie bewegen, dann bleibt der Ball immer da. Also der bewegt sich immer mit. Und das war eben der Ball Holding. Da gibt es auch eine sehr witzige Geschichte dazu. In 2004, da sind wir zum ersten Mal mit den Aibos Weltmeister geworden, da war ich noch nicht dabei. Und ein gutes Konzept war eben, dass man, sobald man den Ball hat, einfach greifen und ins gegnerische Tor laufen. Und weil wir eine gute Lokalisierung hatten, konnten die Roboter das auch tun. Das heißt, du wusstest ganz genau, wo sie sind, und konntest hinterher dann so ein bisschen blind ins Tor laufen.
So wie Schubkarre?
Ja, genau. Und die konnten natürlich ziemlich präzise dribbeln. Und dann wurde dieses Konzept von Bow-Holding eingeführt, dass man das nicht mehr machen darf. Das heißt, die Regeln emergieren schon aus Erfahrung. Und mit dem Nao wird das natürlich etwas schwierig. Wir können den Ball nicht irgendwie einklemmen, weil der steht relativ frei. Der kann auch nicht mit der Hand oder so den Ball festhalten. Das heißt, er muss ihn frei dribbeln. Das heißt, anspielen und dann weiter. Und das ist ziemlich schwierig. Unsere Strategien richten sich eher danach, wenn ich in der eigenen Spielhälfte bin, dann schieße ich eher grob nach vorne. Hauptsache, der Ball ist weg. Und wenn ich in der gegnerischen Hälfte bin, dann versuche ich mich so auszurichten, dass der Ball genau in der Linie zwischen mir und dem Tor ist, und dann zu schießen. Das Dribbeln ist schwierig. Das heißt, wir versuchen nicht den Ball zu führen oder an einem umzudribbeln oder so was. Das heißt, wir versuchen eher mit kleinen Schüssen oder einfach nur gegen den Ball laufen. Aber dann ist es auch sehr fragwürdig, wo der Ball eigentlich dann hinterher landet.
Aber müsste eigentlich schon das langfristige Ziel sein, oder dass man den Ball abdecken kann und ein paar Tricks machen kann.
Aber hinzu kommt natürlich auch noch der technische Aspekt. Das heißt, was wir momentan eigentlich machen, ist, dass wir einen Satz von Bewegungen haben, die wir aufrufen können. Das heißt, wir haben quasi vorgenerierte Bewegungstriktorien, die wir dann in gewissen Situationen abhängig von der Situation natürlich selber aufrufen und die abspielen können. Das heißt aber, dass diese vorgenerierten Bewegungen natürlich auch nur in genau passenden Situationen zum Ziel führen. Und ein Ansatz wäre jetzt das zu dynamisieren, dass wir es quasi parametrisieren können. Das heißt, wenn die Situation ein bisschen anders ist als die Situation, die wir eigentlich trainiert haben, dass er immer noch gut agieren kann. Und da sind wir gerade auch dabei, das so ein bisschen technisch umzusetzen, dass man halt sagt, okay, wir gehen weg von einfach vorgefertigten Bewegungsabläufen, die wir abspulen, hin zu mehr Dynamisierung, dass wir halt die Situation in Form von Algorithmen erfassen und dann halt unsere Bewegung auch dementsprechend anpassen. Also muss ich quasi vorstellen, das eine ist, von der Technik her, wir haben ein sogenanntes Motion-Net, was aus verschiedenen Posen des Roboters besteht. Und das wird dann einfach abgespult. Das heißt, die Posen laufen mit Zeitkonstanten einfach ab. Und dadurch entsteht die Bewegung. Ein anderer Ansatz wäre, dass man an der Sensor-Einkopplung und der Situation, wie man sich gerade im Spielfeld befindet, eine Bewegung generiert und dann eben die Bewegung ausführt. Und genau in diese Richtung wollen wir uns eigentlich bewegen, weil das viel dynamisierbarer ist. Und natürlich auch dann könnten wir sowas realisieren wie eben dribbeln. Weil beim dribbeln hat der Ball schon mit einer gewissen Unsicherheit sich natürlich auch bewegt. Und wir natürlich immer diese Unsicherheit mit einbeziehen müssen, um den Ball führen zu können. Und mit unserem jetzigen Konzept sind wir da klar an Grenzen. Also man kann das natürlich irgendwie einhängen, man kann versuchen, das allgemein genug zu halten. Man kann natürlich auch einfach einen Riesensatz an Bewegungen vorgenerieren und die dann abrufen. Aber das ist ja eigentlich auch nicht da, wo wir hinwollen. Wir wollen ja schon hin, dass der Roboter in der Lage ist, seine Situation zu erkennen und sich dann zielrichtig zu verhalten. Und wenn möglich auch seine Werkzeuge immer anpassen kann. Dass er nicht einfach sagen muss, okay, ich habe nur diese Möglichkeit, die nehme ich jetzt. Sondern dass er wirklich sagen kann, die Situation ist so. Und ich muss jetzt mich ein bisschen anders verhalten als vorher.
Ist denn das so eine harte Vorgabe, dass der Rechner, der alles steuert, auch in dem Roboter selber sein muss? Ich meine, wenn die Dinger eh über WLAN verfügen, könnte man ja auch sagen, ich gebe hier einfach nur alle Sensoren permanent als Stream irgendwie raus. Und dann habe ich irgendwie eine dicke Schachtel, die da hinten steht und die die ganze Zeit diese ganze Sensorik empfängt. Und dann wird eben da mit einem richtigen fetten Rechner mit irgendwie 220 Volt gerechnet und entsprechend zurück die Kommandos gegeben. Das müsste doch eigentlich auch noch schnell genug sein.
Natürlich könnte man das machen. Und das machen die ja auch in dieser Smallsize-Liga. Das heißt, die ganzen Berechnungen und alles finden außerhalb des Roboters statt.
Aber bei der Smallsize-Liga hast du doch gesagt, ist auch Kamera von oben noch zusätzlich. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass jeder einzelne... Weil was ich jetzt meine, ist ja, dass man schon das Konzept der einzelnen Wahrnehmung beibehält, bloß den Steuerrechner externalisiert.
Ja, sicher, also das könnte man machen. Aber bei uns ist eben der Aspekt der Autonomität sehr wichtig. Das heißt, in unserer Liga müssen die Roboter autonom sein.
Das ist jetzt auch die Idee.
Alles samt Stromversorgung. Nur weil man könnte sich auch überlegen, ob man nicht so ein Kabel drüber hängt. Also die Roboter sollen maximal autonom sein.
Was wäre, wenn ihr jetzt über unbegrenzte Rechenleistung verfügt? Unbegrenzt im Sinne von das, was man sich heutzutage so vorstellen kann, wenn man jetzt so einen fetten Desktop-Kübel hat mit vielen Cores und vielleicht noch eine fette Grafikkarte, wo man dann noch die Parallelleistungen der Grafikkarte quasi auch noch zur Berechnung heranziehen kann. Also wo man wirklich Sensor-Informationen und permanente Bewegungen permanent nachrechnen könnte. Würde sich dann an euren Strategien sehr viel ändern?
Zum Teil. Also klar, es gibt einige Sachen, was gerade die Bildverarbeitung betrifft. Das wäre natürlich ein Vorteil, wenn wir das sehr schnell machen könnten. Dann könnten wir auch noch mehr Informationen auswerten. Aber andere Sachen, zum Beispiel Bewegungsapparat, der wäre davon autonom. Also denen würde das nicht viel mehr helfen, wenn wir jetzt mehr rechnen könnten. Klar, vielleicht ein paar Sachen könnte man dann schneller berechnen. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist da eigentlich mehr so die Forschung, die im Vordergrund steht. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass unsere Algorithmen zu langsam sind, sondern wir haben einfach noch nicht einen richtigen Algorithmus gefunden, um das Problem zu lösen. Und beim Verhalten ist es halt so ähnlich. Man kann halt jetzt unglaublich schnell, wenn man einen Riesenrechner hinterhört, ähnlich wie beim Schach, alle Möglichkeiten durchiterrieren. Aber die Idee ist ja auch wieder so ein bisschen, dass man...
Dass es elegant ist....
elegant ist letztendlich. Und eben auch diese Autonomität hat insofern noch einen technischen Aspekt, der man da nicht vergessen sollte. Denn auch wenn sie über WLAN kommunizieren können, ist es in der Vergangenheit immer wieder vorgekommen, dass dieses WLAN einfach mal ausfällt aufgrund der hohen Belastung. Und dann soll der Roboter natürlich immer noch in der Lage sein, irgendwas zu tun. Also er muss quasi erkennen, ich bin jetzt quasi allein auf dem Feld, abgesehen rein von der Kommunikation her. Aber ich muss jetzt immer noch irgendwie handeln. Und in dem Moment wäre halt quasi ein System, das extern ist, unbrauchbar. Und dadurch, dass er halt autonom ist, kann er dann sich selber dann eine Entscheidung treffen, in der Situation, in der er sich befindet, immer noch.
Also ich muss nochmal sozusagen, um die Frage der mehr Leistung anzusprechen, das ist eine sehr interessante Frage, weil wir arbeiten hier mit Systemen, die in einem Preisbereich liegen, die so um vielleicht 5000 rumliegen. Und die Frage ist natürlich, ob man mit mehr Geld mehr machen kann. Also natürlich kann man mehr machen. Ein Beispiel ist unter anderem Curio. Das ist der ASIMO von Honda oder die HRP2. Das sind die momentan am weitesten entwickelten Roboter.
Den ASIMO, den kenne ich, aber was war das dritte?
Das ist der HRP2.
Von?
Ich weiß nicht, das ist das Internforschungsinstitut, aber das ist jetzt keine Firma.
Du redest jetzt von diesem High-End-Vorzeige-Robotern.
Genau, genau.
Das ist der ASIMO, der so schön im Kreis laufen kann.
Richtig, und der kann auch die Treppen steigen und so weiter. Aber man hat ja auch bei dieser interessanten Präsentation gesehen, wo er dann die Treppen steigen sollte. Dann ist er gestolpert, ist er hingefallen. Da kamen zwei Leute rausgerannt und haben so einen Schirm davor getan. Und dann da hinten irgendwas gemacht. Und hier wurde der Schirm weggetragen. Das war eine Riesenpräsentation. Das sind Tausende Menschen im Saal. Und dann war der Schirm weg. Und dann stand der Roboter wieder. Okay, das heißt, die Roboter mit mehr Geld kann man natürlich sicherlich mehr machen. Man kann mehr Manpower reinstecken. Die Roboter bewegen sich auch viel geschmeidiger. Das heißt, die Technik ist auch einfach mal viel besser. Aber wie man sieht, so richtig Fußball spielen können die auch noch nicht. Das heißt, es fehlt einfach nur noch zu sehr. Was heißt hier fehlt? Es ist noch sehr viel zu entwickeln. In der Technik und auch in der Algorithmik. Zum Beispiel der Mensch, der hat nicht fünf Motoren im Bein. Der kann sein Bein bewegen, so wie man das mit zehn Motoren nicht realisieren würde. Das heißt, da müssen ganz andere Bewegungskonzepte hin.
Das sind ja hunderte von Motoren, wenn man das vergleichen wollte.
Ja, das heißt, da müssen ganz andere Konzepte hin. Also von Muskeln und Steuerungskonzepten auch. Was wir jetzt haben, wir haben pro Bein sechs Motoren. Na gut, klar, also können wir da gewisse Freiheitsgrade der Füße nachbilden. Aber das deckt immer noch nicht alles ab.
Sechs Motoren?
Ja.
Zwei im Fußgelenk, eine im Knie und drei in der Hüfte.
Genau.
Pro Bein.
Das heißt, wir können das ausdrehen, wir können das seitlich eindrehen und nach vorne. Ja, genau. Aber das ist einfach nur viel zu wenig. Und man kann natürlich sehr viel damit schon machen. Man kann damit laufen und so weiter. Aber insbesondere diese Frage der Energetik, die ist natürlich sehr aktuell dort. Weil je mehr Motoren, desto mehr Energie fressen die auch. Und desto größer müssen die Batterien sein. Aber je größer die Batterien, desto schwerer, desto mehr fressen die Motoren. Also es ist nun ein interessanter Kreis. Und alle diese Roboter, die haben noch nicht diese menschliche Dynamik. Das heißt, es gibt ganz andere Forschungsgruppen, die an der Dynamik des Laufens forschen. Die arbeiten dann zum Beispiel mit solchen Passive-Walker-Modellen. Passive-Walker, das sind passive Laufmodellen.
Das sind so Roboter, die eigentlich auf Basis ihrer mechanischen Konstruktion schon von sich aus laufen.
Ja, das sind aber weniger Roboter. Das sind dann so Laufkonstruktionen, Laufmaschinen, teilweise auch ohne Motoren, wo dann kleinste Neigung erreicht, damit sie nach vorne laufen. Also man kennt diese Spielzeuge, die noch nach vorne dackeln.
Also sie kippen sich sozusagen selber in die Stabilität.
Und die physikalischen Kräfte werden einfach perfekt ausgenutzt.
Das heißt, man muss nicht jetzt wirklich alles machen mit ziehen und so weiter, sondern man nutzt mehr so die eigene Dynamik aus.
Und der menschliche Bewegungsapparat ist einfach nicht nur energieeffizient, der ist auch selbst stabilisierend. Das heißt, selbst wenn man stolpert, stabilisiert sich das Laufen, nicht nur aufgrund der riesigen kognitiven Leistung des Menschen, weil man irgendwie die visuellen Daten auswertet und dann sich im Klaren darüber wird, wie man seinen Fuß zu bewegen hat, um eben mit dem nächsten Schritt diesen Stolper auszugleichen. Sondern das passiert zum großen Teil automatisch. Und das haben wir eben noch nicht. Das heißt, der Roboter, das ist wie so ein Kind, das heißt, der macht sich Gedanken über Sachen. Also denkt zum Beispiel ganz genau darüber nach, was er mit seinem Fuß tut. Also das tut kein Mensch.
Beziehungsweise, wenn das nicht tut, dann fällt das auch hin.
Ja, richtig. Das heißt, da muss sich eben klar sein, wie seine Lage ist und so. Und dann ganz bedacht die Filter vorne setzen.
Kann man das Reflexe nennen?
Noch nicht.
Aber das ist eigentlich das, was man haben will. Also wir haben Ausgleichreflexe.
Also die Reflexe könnte man ja so deuten, dass man irgendwie, man hat als Mensch jetzt gesehen, man hat einen Input, also irgendwelche Sensordaten, Gleichgewicht letztendlich. Und daraus wird dann autonom gehandelt. Bei uns wäre es dann mehr so, wir haben zwar auch Sensordaten, die aber teilweise sehr anders gestaltet sind als die, die ein Mensch zur Verfügung hat.
Gibt es einen Gleichgewichtssensor?
Wir haben einen Lagesensor. Also wir haben einen Gyrometer in dem Roboter. Und wir haben halt die Beschleunigensensor. Mit dem könnten wir eigentlich, also wenn wir die beiden Informationen zusammennehmen, könnten wir sowas herstellen. Aber die Frage ist immer, wie gut es ist und vor allem, wie schnell können wir es verarbeiten. Also ich meine, die haben auch irgendwie Taktraten. Und ich meine, so ein Fall, da können schon 20 Millisekunden entscheiden sein, ob wir die noch auffangen können oder nicht mehr. Das heißt, wir müssen diese Daten halt entgegennehmen. Wir müssen sie verarbeiten. Wir müssen sie irgendwie konsolidieren, weil sie jetzt natürlich sehr verrauscht sind. Und müssen dann daraus die Bewegung generieren. Das heißt, der ganze Apparat, letztendlich geht er doch wieder über die ganze Befehlskette entlang, bis es dann ausgeführt wird. Und wir würden halt einfach sagen, als Manager ist es so, das passiert irgendwo im Hintergrund und wir reagieren einfach drauf. Aber das macht nicht unser Bewusstsein, sondern das macht ein ganz anderer Teil. Und das haben wir momentan einfach nicht. Das heißt, das müsste sozusagen in der Hardware schon drinstecken, dass man das kompensieren könnte.
Das erinnert mich auch gerade an die Problematik, die die Vierflügler, die Quadrocopter haben. Da habe ich vor sechs Ausgaben hier bei Chaos Radio Express auch eine Sendung zugehabt, wo gerade diese Sensorik und die Problematik der Selbststabilisierung ein großes Thema waren. Nur mal so nebenbei. Was ist denn hier mit, ich meine, ihr habt ja schon durchklinken lassen, so Fußball an sich als kulturelles Phänomen ist nicht so ganz eure Nachmittagsbeschäftigung. Trotz alledem, denke ich mir, könnte man doch auch daraus eine Menge lernen. Spiele werden dadurch gewonnen, dass man die richtige Strategie hat, dass man sozusagen die Vorteile, die man hat, auch ausspielt und die Nachteile, die man offensichtlich hat, eine Strategie wählt, die sozusagen diese Nachteile nicht zum Tragen kommt. Ist das nicht auch etwas, von dem man viel lernen könnte?
Natürlich könnte man davon viel lernen. Allerdings ist der Sichtpunkt sehr wichtig, weil wenn man die Menschen fragt, was für die so kompliziert ist, was für einen Menschen schwierig ist oder kompliziert, dann nennen sie solche Probleme wie Mathematik, das ist schwierig, das ist Rechnen, ist nicht mein Ding und so weiter. Aber keiner sagt irgendwie, dass es schwierig ist, eine Tür zu öffnen oder zu gehen. Das heißt, während Menschen Fußball spielen, dann konzentrieren sie sich auf ganz andere Probleme als die, die wir jetzt primär haben. Das heißt, das Laufen an sich ist ein Problem. Natürlich kann man auch Strategien lernen, wie die Menschen das tun, wie sie sich verhalten und das tun sie auch in der Simulations-Liga sehr stark. Aber wir können da momentan noch nicht sehr viel draus gewinnen, weil wir eigentlich dieses Rüstzeug, wie du erwähnt hast, diese basic Skills noch nicht perfekt beherrschen.
Das heißt, das steckt alles noch im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes in den Kinderschulen?
Ja, gewissermaßen. Vor allem das Spielen mit diesen humanoiden Robotern. Das wird erst seit zwei, drei Jahren gemacht. Jetzt gibt es diesen Now. Das heißt, das ist noch relativ am Anfang, obwohl wir schon zehn Jahre dabei sind.
Aber das sind schon zehn Jahre, nicht? Richtig.
Das stimmt allerdings, weil es gab auch sehr viele Erfolge. Es gibt im Internet einige Videos. Wer interessiert, kann sich danach informieren. Wenn man die Spiele von 1997 von den Aibos vergleicht, wo die dann so sich nun ja...
So ein bisschen apathisch rumstehen und ab und zu auch mal einen Schuss machen.
Genau, die zucken dann so ein bisschen durch die Gegend. Wenn der Ball weggerollt ist, dann ist der verzweifelt. Dann braucht er erst mal eine Minute, um sich umzudrehen und zu gucken, wo er überhaupt ist. Und dann fällt schon mal ein Tor pro Spiel oder zwei. Die letzten Spiele, die gingen dann so zehn, zwölf aus und so weiter. Und wenn man schwachen Gegner hat, dann schießt man auch mal zehn Tore in eine Halbzeit. Und dann wird das Spiel vorzeitig abgewippt. Ach echt, das gibt es auch? Ja, also das Spiel, das Team kann ja aufgeben.
Ach wirklich, aber das fehlt nicht am Ende. Das holt ihr aber nur im K.O.-System dann.
Ja, also nochmal auf die Frage einzugehen, was es betrifft mit diesen, ob wir noch in den Kinderschuhen stecken. Letztendlich ist das ja auch der Grund, warum es diese verschiedenen Ligen gibt. Weil man möchte sich jetzt nicht nur auf einen Bereich spezialisieren. Man möchte nicht warten, bis man die ganzen Basics erlernt hat und sich dann über die höheren Dinge den Kopf zerbrechen, sondern möchte eigentlich parallel entwickeln. Und man möchte eben auch vor allem Menschen, die verschieden interessiert sind, dafür begeistern. Das heißt, man macht diese Simulationsliga, die dann doch mehr für das Verhalten eigentlich zuständig ist und eben genau solche Spielprinzipien, die im realen Fußballleben existent sind, übernommen werden und dort eben auf den Roboter portiert oder auf den Agenten viel mehr in diese Simulationen portiert werden. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es halt gerade unsere Teams, also die Teams, die mit der wirklichen Hardware agieren, die mehr diese Basics-Probleme lösen wollen. Und wir natürlich auch eben die Unbekannter der Umgebung und eben die verrauschten Daten, mit denen wir nun mal zu kämpfen haben, irgendwie dafür eine Kompensation schaffen. Und letztendlich sind das sozusagen verschiedene Entwicklungen, strenge, die da verfolgt werden in diesen verschiedenen Ligen. Darum ist es auch so interessant, dass wir verschiedene Ligen haben. Und im besten Fall, wenn wir uns gut weiterentwickeln, können wir die dann irgendwann mal zu einem großen ganzen zusammenfügen. Das wäre so der Hauptaspekt.
Was simuliert denn diese Simulation eigentlich? Ich meine, die simuliert doch jetzt sicherlich nicht Aibos, sondern die simuliert dann doch schon Spieler oder...
Also ich glaube, das Spielermodell ist ziemlich simplifiziert. Das heißt, es gibt einfach einen Spieler, der in einer bestimmten Position ist und der halt Informationen über die Objekte um ihn herum bekommt. Und der kann dann aus der Situation halt agieren. Es wird jetzt kein physikalisches Modell angestrebt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass die Simulationsliga, die wissen, dass sie zwei Arme, zwei Beine haben, sondern...
Ja, das nicht. Aber was passiert in so Sachen wie Erschöpfung oder so, dass man nicht irgendwie die ganze Zeit rennen kann wie ein Beklopter?
Ist sowas da drin? Also da bin ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz informiert. Weil wir haben da nicht gespielt in dieser Liga. Also ich weiß nicht, ob da Erschöpfung ist. Aber es gibt zumindest mehrere Simulations-Ligen. Es gibt zum Beispiel mittlerweile auch eine 3D-Simulations-Liga, wo ich die auch eine physikalische Simulation habe. Das heißt, die spielen mit einem Simulator auch richtig und versuchen auch den Roboter zu steuern. Aber die älteste Liga ist, wie Oliver schon richtig gesagt hat, das ist die 2D-Simulations-Liga. Da simulieren die wirklich nur den Roboter als eine gewissermaßen Position. Die haben einen Aktionsradius und die können eine Aktion ausführen. Diese Aktion hat eine gewisse Unsicherheit. Die haben eine Reihe von abstrakten Aktionen, die dann so was heißen wie Kick mit einem gewissen Parameter. Diese Aktion hat auch eine gewisse Unsicherheit. Das heißt, da passiert irgendwas mit dem Ball, abhängig davon, ob er in meinem Wirkungsbereich ist oder außerhalb meines Wirkungsbereiches. Das heißt, die sind schon etwas eingeschränkt. Die können zum Beispiel auch nur auf eine gewisse Distanz kommunizieren. Man kann nicht über das ganze Feld schreien. Und die haben auch einen zusätzlichen Spieler im Team, der nicht auf dem Feld ist, sondern am Rand sitzt und den Trainer darstellt. Der hat so ein bisschen den Überblick und kann den Spielern was zurufen. Also der kann dann die coachen.
Da gibt es dann sozusagen wirklich eine richtige Simulation. Da spielt er wahrscheinlich auch die Strategien an, die größere Wanne, oder?
Ja, das ist richtig. Das ist auch sozusagen der Hauptaspekt der Simulationsliga. Aber der wesentliche Unterschied, sage ich mal, der diese simulierten Fußballs zu dem von mir am Anfang gewähnten FIFA Soccer 2000 oder 2005, was auch immer, Spiel ist, dass jede Agenda, das heißt, jeder Spieler wird durch ein gekapseltes Programm dargestellt. Das ist ein separater Prozess, der eben diese Eingangs- und Ausgangskanäle hat. Das heißt, er hat gewisse Informationen, die er reinbekommt von seinen Mitspielern, von seiner Umwelt. Und das wird auch alles simuliert, was er eigentlich sehen sollte. Wenn er in diese Richtung schauen würde, dann bekommt er so Information. Na ja, du siehst ein Tor in etwa so und so einer Entfernung. Oder du siehst eben eine Landmark. Und das heißt, es sind elf separate Programme, die da laufen, also beziehungsweise zwölf oder eben 24, die dann gegeneinander antreten. Das heißt, die haben nicht den Überblick über das gesamte Feld. Das sind wirklich Agenten. Einzelne Spieler noch. Die haben aber, wie Oliver schon erwähnt hat, jetzt eben nicht das Problem der Physik an dieser Stelle. Also die in der 3D-Simulation, die versuchen schon auch, die physikalische Welt auch zu simulieren. Also die komplette Welt. Aber die Liga ist auch relativ neu und die haben auch sehr viele Schwierigkeiten.
Ja, so kommt auch die Tatsache, dass eben die simulierte physikalische Welt nicht unbedingt deckungsgleich mit der realen physikalischen Welt ist.
Aber es ist zumindest erstmal eine.
Genau, also wir haben ja selber die Erfahrung gemacht, da wir auch viel mit dem Simulator gearbeitet haben für unseren Roboter, dass wir halt Sachen, die wir dort entwickelt haben, nicht ohne weiteres auf den richtigen Roboter portieren können. Das heißt, wir müssen immer noch wieder Anpassungen machen und in der simulierten Welt geht einiges besser als in der Realität.
Und das ist ganz witzig, die ersten Spiele in der 3D-Simulationsliga haben stattgefunden mit riesigen Kugeln. Also die Spieler waren so Kugeln, also das Modell einer Kugel. Ja, genau. Und die sind dann durch das Feld gerollt. Also jetzt mittlerweile sind die humanoid, aber...
Ja, ich vermute mal und unterstelle euch, dass ihr den Bereich als recht spannend und für einen Informatiker auch sehr ergiebig halten würdet. Was könnt ihr denn so, was sind so eure Empfehlungen an Leute, die vielleicht in diesem Themenfeld Interesse haben, wie man sich dem nähern kann?
Ja, welche Art denn von Interesse? Also wenn man da einsteigen möchte oder...
Na ja, das klingt ja jetzt erstmal alles ganz spannend und so. Und jetzt weiß ja man, wie das ist, wenn man mit sowas noch nicht vertraut ist, dann fragt man sich immer, wie gehe ich denn da jetzt am besten ran? Kaufe ich mir meine Box-Lego Mindstorms? Ist das irgendwie schon mal ein ganz guter Einstieg?
Oder wird man sich gebraucht in Aibo?
Also eigentlich ist das irgendein, was man halt machen möchte. Man könnte sich zu Anfang mit den Simulatoren, die auf dem Markt sind, mal angucken. Die sind teilweise auch als Demo-Version verfügbar. Das heißt, man könnte schon mal einfach auf die Art und Weise mit dem Roboter erste Kontakte knüpfen. Und dann als weiteres, klar, man könnte dann sehen, dass man sich halt einen einfachen Bausatzzwecht besorgt oder einen einfachen Roboter. Und natürlich in letzter Konsequenz, wenn man jetzt...
Würdest du empfehlen, ich meine, das werden jetzt schon so einige diskutiert.
Also ich persönlich habe mal... Den ersten Roboter, den ich irgendwie gebaut habe und auch bis jetzt mein einziger, das ist der Asuro vom DLR entwickelt. Das ist nichts anderes als eine Platine mit zwei Rädern. Der hat keine Kamera, gar nichts. Also der hat einfache Testsensoren und der hat Infrarotsensoren, womit er dann auch Linien erkennen kann. Und das Nettet an ihm ist einfach ein Bausatz für 50 Euro. Das heißt, man investiert nicht viel Geld, man muss ein bisschen löten können. Baut sich den zusammen innerhalb eines Tages. Und dann kann man den ganz normal programmieren mit C++ bzw. Und da läuft ein Armchip drauf. Das heißt, embedded system Programmierung. Und da hat man schon mal so ein Gefühl, was eigentlich die Robotik ausmacht. Das ist zwar auf einem ganz anderen Niveau als jegliche anderen Roboter-Bausätze, die ich gesehen habe, aber das ist ein guter Einstieg. Also war für mich jedenfalls ein Einstieg, auch wenn man gerade so ein bisschen hardware-orientiert ist.
Und diese Mindstorms-Geschichte ist ja recht populär eigentlich.
Genau, da habe ich mich selber persönlich nie mit beschäftigt. Aber das ist natürlich auch ein netter Einstieg. Wobei ich glaube, das ist aber vom Kostenfaktor ein bisschen höher. Ich glaube, der Mindstorm liegt so 100 bis 300 Euro, muss man glaube ich investieren, wenn man einen vernünftigen Bausatz haben möchte. Vor allem, weil es auch modular gestaffelt ist, man kann dann so glaube ich die Teile einzeln kaufen und dann auch erweitern. Hat natürlich seinen Vorteil. Ansonsten gibt es noch Fischertechnik, die sind schon ziemlich lange in diesem Bereich tätig. Die bieten auch verschiedene Bausätze, wobei die auch meistens so Experimentierbausätze mehr so haben. Da geht es also weniger darum, dass man einen konkreten Roboter baut, mit dem man dann irgendwas machen kann, sondern wo man so einzelne Aspekte experimentieren kann, also Arme, Hände, Beine an sich und solche Geschichten. Das ist mir so der Forscheraspekt, der verfüglich wird. Wie gesagt, und sonst würde ich einfach, wer Interesse hat, einfach mal die YouTube-Videos durchgucken. Es gibt ziemlich viele, die sich mit Robotik beschäftigen, wo dann selbst Bauten gezeigt werden. Die YouTube-Videos?
Na ja, welche meinst du denn?
Naja, ich würde einfach mal das Wort Robotik eintippen. RoboCup einfach? RoboCup ist natürlich sehr speziell. RoboCup ist natürlich auf uns ausgerichtet. Aber wenn man sich jetzt für Robotik im Allgemeinen interessiert, dann sollte man dort mal als erstes gucken, was es überhaupt so für Sachen gibt. Weil auch die Hersteller selber da Videos reingestellt haben, um zu sehen, was für einen Funktionsumfang sie haben und vor allem auch die Namen der Hersteller finden. Weil es gibt keinen Global Player in diesem Bereich zurzeit. Es gibt halt verschiedene, kleinere Firmen, die ihre Roboterprodukte an den Markt bringen wollen. Und da sollte man einfach mal gucken.
Ja, ich habe noch eine Empfehlung. Und zwar, wenn man jetzt nicht unbedingt in den Bereich der Hardware gehen möchte und wenn man das nicht unbedingt löten möchte, sondern sich eher für die kognitive oder eben gesagt die deliberative Aspekte in der Robotik oder insgesamt der künstlichen Intelligenz interessiert, dann gibt es diverse Simulatoren, die man jetzt nehmen könnte, um eben seine Algorithmen zu probieren, auch Bildverarbeitung oder auch Verhalten insbesondere. Also da gibt es einen Simulator, den wir jetzt auch benutzen, das heißt Webbots oder V-Bots, wie auch immer man das ausspricht, den gibt es frei.
Also W-E-Bots?
Ja, genau. Also wenn man das bei Google eintippt, dann findet man das schon.
Also nicht wie die Nintendo Wii, sondern...
Nein, nein, genau. W-Bots. Und die ist nicht frei, allerdings gibt es dort Demo-Versionen, die in verschiedenen Kontext-Modi betrieben werden können. Das heißt diese Firma, das heißt Cyberbotics, glaube ich, die schreiben so Wettbewerbe aus und die sind dann frei. Das heißt, man kann diesen Simulator sich runterladen und innerhalb dieser Wettbewerbe frei programmieren. Man kann so Controller für die simulierten Roboter schreiben. Und das Interessante ist, da gibt es verschiedene Roboter. Da gibt es zum Beispiel diese kleinen Roboter mit den Rädern, die es auch zu kaufen gibt. Das sind, glaube ich, Creperer-Roboter oder so. Und die werden da simuliert in einem Labyrinth, wo die dann gegeneinander antreten, so zwei Roboter, und die müssen solche Energiequellen sammeln. Das heißt Rats Life, also die Ratte, die am längsten überlebt, die hat gewonnen. Und das Witzige ist, es gibt seit dem letzten Jahr ein Internetwettbewerb, das heißt Robot Stadium. Da spielen die Naos, die simulierten Naos, in einer simulierten Welt. Und man kann einen Controller schreiben in C, C++ oder Java und seinen Code dann auf einer Seite hochladen und dann spielt die eigene simulierte Mannschaft gegen eine andere. Und dann kann man richtig am Ende des Tages seine Ergebnisse sehen. Und dann kann man eben aufsteigen und dann kann man auch Weltmeister werden in diesem Wettbewerb. Und dieser Wettbewerb ist offen für jeden und das ist, glaube ich, ganz spannend. Und da kann man auch am Ende, glaube ich, einen Nao gewinnen, wo man gesiegt hat.
Gibt es denn irgendwelche Open Source oder Free Software-Projekte, die sich so mit Robotik beschäftigen? So Systeme, die komplett frei daherkommen?
Ja, es gibt eine Menge an Teams, die eben auch ihren eigenen Simulator entwickelt haben. Also mir ist jetzt bewusst, nur es gibt die SimSpark-Umgebung, die, ich weiß gar nicht, von wem die entwickelt wurde, aber die quasi bildet ein Open Source-Äquivalenz so der Rebots-Version.
Ja, von der Community, die wird von der Simulations-Liga-Community entwickelt.
Aber eine Uni ist da, wie ich weh dafür entdrücke, mir ist der Name gerade nicht bewusst. Aber wenn man danach googelt, dann findet man schon die entsprechenden Seiten. Und da ist diese ganze Umgebung, wenn man sie runterlädt, da sind verschiedene Roboter drin, es gibt das Spielfeld.
Du könnt den Link auch noch hier mit in die Show geben.
Das ist halt eine Open Source-Version, die ist momentan aber auch nur auf Linux-Lauffähig, soweit ich das weiß. Das heißt, die wird noch ziemlich weiterentwickelt. Die ist auch noch recht jung. Ansonsten bin ich der Meinung, dass einige Universitäten auch noch für Simulatoren für ihre eigenen Roboter entwickelt haben, um die Physik zu simulieren, wo man nicht wirklich gegeneinander spielen kann, sondern wo man wirklich nur Bewegungsabläufe der Roboter testen kann. Ich glaube, die Universität Bremen oder die Universität Harmenstadt hat, glaube ich, einen Simulator, der auch recht gut ist.
Die Bremer, ja. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob die den offengelegt haben.
Ach so, gut.
Also die verwenden das jetzt für die eigenen Projekte, aber ich weiß nicht, ob die den jetzt offengelegt haben.
Genau. Ja, ansonsten andere Simulationsumgebungen würden mir jetzt nicht einfallen.
Und so im Hardware-Bereich, gibt es da irgendwas, so offene Ansätze, Hardware, Robotik zu bauen? Und ist das noch so schwierig, so einen Roboter zu bauen? Hört da so viel dazu? Kriegt man nicht die ganzen Motoren und Systeme irgendwie?
Ja klar, eigentlich kann man alles kaufen. Also das ist nicht das Problem. Aber es ist halt erstmal eine Kostenfrage. Und zum anderen eben muss man auch das Know-how haben, sie zu verarbeiten. Und es gibt einige Foren. Also mir fällt es nur roboternetz.de ein. Das ist ein Forum und eine Wikipedia-Seite, also eine Wikiseite, die dann Informationen aufbereitet, wo irgendwelche Projekte veröffentlicht wurden. Und die bieten halt in ihrem Forum guten Support, welche Motoren und welche Schaltplatten man benutzen sollte. Ja, aber so die Roboter, die dort veröffentlicht werden, sind dann doch eher auf niedrigerem Niveau. Also es sind dann einfache Platten-Sachen, die man da bauen kann. Aber es kommen zum Beispiel keine Humanoiden-Roboter als Projekte. Habe ich da nicht gesehen dort. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall, das ist doch in den letzten Jahren immer mehr geworden, schon eine Community, aber also jetzt in Deutschland und in den Staaten vor allem, da ist mir das aufgefallen, dass immer mehr Leute halt sich mit dem Aspekt auch außerhalb der Universität beschäftigen und eben auch eigene gute Konzepte dort an den Mann bringen wollen, beziehungsweise einfach auch veröffentlichen, ohne dass sie dafür jetzt Geld haben wollen. Also es macht schon Sinn, da einfach mal ein bisschen Recherche zu betreiben. Ein richtig großes Forum, wo irgendwie alles verlinkt ist, so habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gefunden, ist es dann doch ein bisschen Handarbeit, diese Informationen rauszusuchen.
Ich sehe gerade beim Roboternetz, da gibt es dann, wenn man sich anmeldet, auch so eine interaktive Benutzerkarte, wo die Leute, die sich da engagieren, auch sich geografisch verorten, sodass wenn man seinen eigenen kleinen Robotertreff aufbauen möchte, da vielleicht auch fündig werden könnte. Gibt es sonst noch irgendwelche nennenswerten Ressourcen, die man auf jeden Fall mal durchgelesen haben sollte, um sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen?
Na gut, die Detatur ist ja echt breitgefächert.
Ja, ich weiß, aber gibt es vielleicht trotzdem sowas wie das Buch, was man mal gelesen haben muss, weil man das sowieso in jedem Zettelpaper zitieren muss, weil es irgendwie so beanträchtend war?
Nee, also ich habe ein Buch gefunden, das nennt sich selbst das Handbook of Robotics. Das ist ein recht umfangreiches Werk, ist auch recht teuer, ich glaube 250 Euro. Das ist also nicht unbedingt für einen Einsteiger, da steht wirklich alles drin. Also wird im jeden Themenbereich angesprochen, sagen wir es mal so. Aber das ist natürlich ein sehr wissenschaftliches Werk und eben auch sehr teuer. Ansonsten wirklich jetzt Fachbücher wäre mir gerade egal.
Na ja, also was heißt ja Fachbücher? Die Frage ist natürlich, in welchem Bereich bewegen wir uns, weil wir haben gerade über Bausätze gesprochen. Und wenn man jetzt über Literatur spricht, das heißt Bücher, dann muss man sich fragen, jetzt Literatur für Bausätze oder jetzt Literatur zum Beispiel für irgendwelche Selbstlokalisierungsverfahren oder so ähnliche Sachen. Also in diesem Bereich, da wäre zum Beispiel, also da gibt es schon, da könnte man sagen, das Buch, das heißt Probabilistic Robotics. Das heißt also, wenn man sich jetzt da für sich etwas interessiert, dann kann man das Buch nehmen und da werden viele Konzepte auch relativ einfach erklärt, wo man zum Beispiel auch in seinem, ja die man auch eigentlich auch selbst umsetzen kann, mit seinem Programmcode. Also wenn man jetzt Hardware haben möchte, dann bräuchte man dann eine Hardware, das heißt ein Roboter, die sich in einer Welt bewegt, in einem Kasten oder was auch immer, wenn man das im kleinen Raum aufbauen möchte. Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn man in einem Simulator einen Roboter kontrolliert, dann kann man die Verfahren auch dort anwenden. Aber wie gesagt, das Buch ist aus dem wissenschaftlichen Bereich.
Also das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen für den Fortgeschrittenen. Oder besonders Ambitionierten. Aber man weiß ja immer nicht, wer hier so zuhört bei Chaos Radio Express. Ich denke, wir sind jetzt hier am Ende angekommen. Gibt es noch irgendwas Wichtiges, was wir hätten noch erwähnen sollen, was von mir nicht ausreichend hinterfragt worden ist? Was hat der geheime Spickzettel?
Ja genau, wir haben natürlich jetzt auch noch zwei Events dieses Jahr. Vielleicht werden die ganz interessant.
Wo ist denn der nächste RoboCup?
Genau, der nächste RoboCup ist in Graz.
Das ist die Weltmeisterschaft dort.
Das wird vom 29.06. bis 25.07. dieses Jahres. Aber davor gibt es noch in Hannover, auf der Industriemesse in Hannover, vom 20. bis 24. April, die deutschen Meisterschaften.
Direkt auf der Messe in der eigenen Halle.
Letztes Jahr war es so, dass die mit Robotik beschäftigt sind. Da sind wir und andere Teams ein Teil des Programms. Da werden wir auch gegeneinander antreten. Wir werden die deutschen Meister kühlen, bzw. den deutschen Meister erst einmal herausfinden. Der NAO wird natürlich antreten, es werden aber auch die anderen Ligen vertreten sein. Das ist sehr interessant und auch sehr nahe innerhalb Deutschlands. Und Graz kann man eigentlich auch nur einen Wärmsten ins Herz legen, die mal Interesse daran haben, sich das mal vor Ort anzugucken.
Wohl bemerkt, Hannover Messeindustrie, nicht CeBIT. Richtig. Was ganz Interessantes. Das ist sozusagen mehr der Industrie irgendwie näher zu sein scheint oder zumindest von der Messeleitung so kategorisiert wird als der Computertechnik.
Hier zu Thema Veranstaltungen und sich informieren, fällt mir noch ein. Wir werden natürlich auch bei der Langen Nacht der Wissenschaften vertreten sein.
Das ist hier so eine regelmäßige Geschichte in Berlin?
Ja, genau. Lange Nacht der Wissenschaften, wenn man das eintippt, dann findet das irgendwann mal im Juni statt, glaube ich. Und wir sind dann in Adlershof in einem Erwin-Schrödinger-Zentrum, also wenn man nach Adlershof rausfährt oder im Programm schaut. Also da stellen wir auch unser Team vor und unser Roboter, das heißt, wenn sich jemand dafür interessiert.
13. Juni 2009 ist das.
Die ist naoteamhumboldt.de.
Alles ein Wort.
Also alles ein Wort, ja genau.
Und die ist momentan nicht ganz auf dem neuesten Stand, aber wird jetzt demnächst auch wieder mehr gepflegt werden. Da werden also immer die Events, denen wir natürlich teilnehmen, und natürlich auch allgemeine Informationen zum RoboCup und zum Nao speziell, werden dort dann veröffentlicht.
Also das sind auch die Webseiten von einem Aibo-Team, von einem Simulationsteam und von einem Humanoidenteam, die bei uns an der HU sind oder Waren auch verlinkt.
Und Fotos und Videos habt ihr dann natürlich auch. Ja, super. Jetzt haben wir es aber, oder? Dann sage ich vielen Dank, Heinrich, Oliver, für die Ausführung. Ein sehr interessanter Einblick in die Welt der Fußballrobotik bzw. auch ein bisschen überhaupt Robotik, weil soweit ist das ja alles auch nicht auseinander. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Kommentare, wie immer erwünscht, unter blog.chaosradio.ccc.de im Eintrag zu dieser Sendung oder bei schwierigen Nachfragen auch chaosradio.ccc.de Ihr wisst schon, das war Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 112. Sagen wir schon Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.